bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de deux probablement aujourd'hui
je reçois à nouveau mais dit elle même
dit parce que depuis la guerre fois on a
fait un petit bébé ensemble qu'on eut un
petit livret qui s'appelle le tableau
chantier rendre un titre certifié leur
justement bénéfique bouge jamais dit
bonjour mais en fait tu me ressembles je
te reçois aussi parce que tu vas
j'espère beaucoup plus parlé que l'autre
la dernière fois et cie d'avoir un truc
un peu partagé en effet bas du cou donc
méditer tour à l'open mais tu as changé
de statut qu'on peut faire c'est
peut-être mise à jour non ah oui je suis
docteur était devenu de garde pas petite
histoire quand on a soumis la version
finale de ce livre tu n'étais pas encore
officiellement un chercheur docteur dr
alors que de revivre on avait écrit
keith était docteur don qu'il restait
cinq jours pour savoir si elle a démenti
il vous tout s'est bien passé hôpitaux
petit à thèze donc maintenant parlons de
ce truc que tu as écrit ce qu'un accord
est donc le fabuleux chantier peut-être
commencer par donner une idée du global
de ce canal livre
oui d'abord le livre introduit l'urgence
du sujet les gens on n'en a pas parlé
mais ce serait bien de répéter les gens
ne se rendent pas compte de l'urgence de
ce chantier de rendre l'intelligence
artificielle leur opus de moins
bénéfique
typiquement quand ils comptent en compte
les gens en temps de sécurité de
l'intelligence artificielle ou
étiquetage ans artificielle on jeu
d'intelligence artificielle un petit
robot se dessine dans leur tête et il
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
encore très loin mais ils ne se rendent
pas compte que c'est un sujet qui ne
concerne pas le futur lointain mais le
présent maintenant et donc notamment les
algorithmes déjà déployé le litre parle
en long et en large des abris de
recommandations des réseaux sociaux
donc ok d'abord dans l'urgence cette
question d'urgence qui couvrent ouvre le
livre
ensuite nicolas remparts passage en
revue des dégâts déjà qu'ils se
produisent déjà d'une intelligence
artificielle mal déployé et a aussi oui
alors on va utiliser beaucoup le terme
d'intelligence artificielle dans ce
podcast est dans le livre quelque chose
contre est aussi très très très tôt dans
le livre c'est qu'il ne faut pas penser
à 50 ans on va dire intelligence
artificielle dans ce podcast
il ne faut pas s'imaginer skynet au
terminator ou une intelligence qui
dépasse l'humain
tout outil de traitement automatisé de
l'information rentrer dans ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence artificielle donc
un automatisme qui regarde trois posts
sur facebook et des sites lequel vous
allez voir c'est de l'intelligence
artificielle
je propose c'est très bête mais c'est
vrai qu'en france parce que je propose
même c'est que dans ce podcast on parle
d'algorithmes chaque pas exact envers
eux un talent certain
oui je pense que c'est plus sage ce que
moi l'intelligence artificielle amis
parce que tu as honte on en parle
normalement faut attirer l'attention des
gens mais le point commun ses rangs les
algorithmes les plus déployés sur des
milliards de personnes aujourd'hui qui
sont souvent quand même assez
sophistiqué voire très très sophistiqué
qui ont très très très complexe et bien
ses algorithmes la d'aujourd'hui pose
déjà énormément de problèmes et je pense
qu'elles vont revenir sur ce que tu as
dis parce que je suis tout à fait
d'accord d'accord mais moi maintenant ça
ça ça me hérisse voir un peu les poils
de plus en plus on donne à chaque fois
que les gens passent directement de
intelligence artificielle a robot et que
par la suite des robes boucle parce que
des robots ont des propriétés
on leur assigne des probabilités des
propriétés qui sont pas les propriétés
des algorithmes plus influents
d'aujourd'hui et du coup quand on pense
aux robots on pense à des faux pas des
faux problèmes ça me fasse des problèmes
mais c'est pas les problèmes non pas par
exemple un robot c'est très localisés
oui c'est un corps localisés s'il est
dans la chambre 304 il est dans la
chambre 304 alors que les algorithmes
des plus problématiques ne sont pas
localisés centre est délocalisée ils
sont partout algorithmes de
recommandation on ne peut pas le
localiser dans le corps d'un logo qui
vous fait duc afrique mais il est sur
toutes les machines connectées à
internet
et puis mon imaginaire aussi quand on
pense à robben penser à un truc avec
lequel on interagit montant réel du coup
le robot dit des choses à vitesse
humaines alors que nos égoïsmes
d'aujourd'hui youtube on parle à des
millions milliards de personnes
très rapidement à chaque instant et on
peut pas pareil nous prennent du
contrôle ont l'impression qu'il ya un
robot zodiac physique que le crawl et le
localiser il peut l'encercler des
branches est débranché mais quand on
pense à l'algorithme de youtube
tout ça c'est votre corps qui n'ont peur
et donc quoi je pense que c'est un des
aspects importants de seuil et c'est que
on se concentre sur des algorithmes très
déployer d'aujourd'hui du présent et on
dit que ça pose déjà pas mal de
problèmes notamment après les gens vont
dire pourquoi ils s'appellent
l'intelligence artificielle parce qu'en
fait il ya il ya un changement de
paradigme dans l'informatique dû au fait
que les algorithmes puissant aujourd'hui
sont ceux qui apprennent des données et
non pas ceux que l'on a programmé à la
main qu'on peut audités et vérifiées et
donc il ya le côté apprentissage qui est
qui fondamentale qui est fondamental
pour la puissance mais aussi pour les
vulnérabilités
donc voilà pourquoi on a quand même
adopté le terme scientifique c'est
sous-entendre sous-entend apprentissage
qui est associé et je pense qu il
incarne ans compenser ces algorithmes et
plus influents d'aujourd'hui et du futur
et on fait un peu le pari d'en du livre
que qui n'est pas d'ailleurs un pari
important de ne pas une hypothèse
critique du livre mais serait que
beaucoup du livre est orienté vers des
algorithmes d'apprentissage parce que
quand tu dis c'est serré fois les plus
prometteurs mais en plus ils ont des
spécificités des vulnérabilités assez
spécifique qui n'ont pas plu plus
classique
donc oui donc je disais enfin pas sa
passion à leur passage en revue des
qu'on appelle les victimes de lire on
parle bien là là on l'a on va il ya
beaucoup de focalisation sur les
systèmes de recommandations des réseaux
sociaux
je pense que l'actualité des trois
dernières années dans le monde
occidental était riche même en asie
aussi
si on parle donc le cas de dénis amar où
il ya eu 1
selon les termes de l'onu génocide en
cours et selon ce qui a été reconnu par
le patron de facebook lui-même
négligence de la part de facebook
négligence à la fois sur le plan de la
gouvernance mais aussi algorithmique
n'est pas les gens pensent souvent à à
l'intention à chaque fois qu'on parle de
ce type de problème les gens vont
s'attarder à l'intention du designer de
celui qui met en place les algorithmes
les plates formes et dans livres en
explique aussi que c'est pas qu'un
problème d'intentions c'est un problème
technique très difficile donc en train
petit passage en revue de ce que les
trois ou quatre dernières années nous
ont offert comme aperçu de ce qui peut
tourner mal avec les algorithmes
largement déployée j'ai mentionné le cas
du génocide du myanmar ou une
amplification complications
d'information appelons au lynchage aux
meurtres etc
mais on en parle aussi des élections
américaines où il ya eu une manipulation
très très évidente en fait un petit
petit tour des preuves qu'on a jusque-là
de ce que le congrès américain publié de
la thématique la polarisation qui est
que ses algorithmes amplifie on parle de
la question par exemple du ressenti anti
vaccins qui a été listé pour la première
fois par l'om est l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
comme une des dix plus grandes menaces
sur la santé publique en 2019 rappelant
que les mêmes des maladies comme la
rougeole la varicelle
c'est très très mortels et donc quand
des algorithmes profonde à promotion du
l'opinion anti vaccin c'est pas juste ce
n'est pas juste des débats de comptoir
que sarah que ça va que ça va amplifier
ça va aussi mener à certains des ces
lieux de podcasts en avait parlé une
petite épidémie pas très loin de nous en
suisse sa marge dans un dans une école
mais il ya des gens plus de cas de décès
d'enfants ou de maladies graves dus à la
machination et beaucoup d' enquête
révèle que le ressentiment anti vaccin a
été amplifiée par par des algorithmes
qui essayent de maximiser la tension est
donc voilà je pense que tu peux être
enchaînés sur les la question de la
tension
ouais clairement parce que on attend
c'est aussi comme tu disais à penser que
le gros problème c'est l'intention des
intentions pas l'attention des
l'intention les débuts des programmeurs
section une critique que l'on fait et
c'est clairement un aspect important on
nie absolument pas et il faut absolument
que il beaucoup plus d'efforts de
sensibilisation à ces risques dans
toutes ses entreprises clairement mais
aussi en dollars parce qu'on vise
beaucoup d entreprises mais je pense que
on a tous les deux en tête aussi
beaucoup les chercheurs ont donc
d'académique qui certains vont même
dénigrer la recherche sur andy est
bénéfique en disant parce qu'il ya un
peu cet aspect est un peu cet aspect là
il ya la recherche de pointe les
meilleurs quoi c'est un peu les
médailles fields l'équivalent du
médaille fields en informatique ils vont
être ceux qui vont battre l'état de
l'art sur tel truc
et puis un peu et un peu cette idée que
lorsqu'on n'arrive pas à faire ça on se
rabat sur des problèmes secondaires du
coude et prennent par exemple rendre lui
est bénéfique comme si c'était pas digne
des plus grands chercheurs
je pense qu'ils ont une idée qu'on
cherche à combattre est que non il ya
des points fantastiques pourront déjà
bénéfique
ce sera sans doute plus difficile de
juger qui est en fait le truc le plus
plus impressionnant de plus prestigieux
mais c'est des recherches qui est
vraiment fascinante est vraiment
important dans la difficile si je peux
faire une sortie un peu du cadre de
livres aussi dans quoi en parlant des
chats l'un des défis mathématique si
elle est mathématicien qui nous écoutent
par exemple si on prend le domaine de la
statistique robuste c'est un domaine
très vieux les plus grands travaux ont
été faits dans les années 80 par un
belge où se met cesser les prémices de
la statistique robuste on peut les
remontées jusqu'à fred weber et ferma où
on veut par exemple
agrégé des points et il ya des points
qui sortent du lot qui sont pas dans la
tendance globale est parmi les premières
idées qu'on a vu c'est la médiane on
agrège les salaires d'une ville si on
prend le salaire moyen il va pas reflété
le citoyen typique de cette ville alors
on va prendre le salaire médian
et quand les données sont
multidimensionnelles c'est pas juste un
salaire ça devient un peu plus difficile
de sortir une médiane et dans quoi le
domaine de la statistique robuste s'est
réapproprié cette question dans les
années 60 où quelques années 70 donc que
le comédien de touques et puis après il
ya eu donc leur sève qui a en 38 85
avaient prouvé que la médiane
géométriques et l'ellipse au 8 de plus
faibles volumes sont des estimateurs
robuste en grande dimension et ce qui
est intéressant à voir c'est que dans
les travaux de cette communauté de
statisticiens il ya un papier jusqu'en
2009 j'ai trouvé la semaine dernière de
lui-même rousseff donc presque trente
ans après centre sans papiers sur la
médiane géométriques qui traite encore
de données quand il va parler d'exemple
empirique les données sont
multidimensionnelles mais de dimensions
c'est c'est en fait ce qui va se passer
c'est que donc la statistique robuste va
développer des outils solides
par exemple si on part si on pense en
fait que news défectueux s'est passé des
données d d d d en créer par exemple une
fake mieux sur youtube ça va être une
vidéo où le titre ne correspond pas au
contenu de la vidéo ou alors une vidéo
où le propos ne correspond pas à ce qui
est observé et empiriquement exemple une
vidéo qui vous dit deux parties et là
vous tartiner la main avec du citron
pour guérir d'un cancer terminal
donc si je si le titre de la vidéo c'est
le citron guéri du cancer terminal
le titre est un label et le propos tenus
dans la vidéo ne guérit pas du cancer
terminal donc annoncé c'est une sorte de
une sorte de données ou le label ne
correspond pas au fitur j c'est une
sorte de fausse information
et donc si on voit les fausses
informations comme des vidéos par
exemple où le label est mensonger
on devrait invoquer la statistique
robuste pour agréger les recommandations
du tube sauf que tout l'arsenal de la
statistique robuste jusqu'en 2009 2010
du mi 2016 même 2013 2013 je suis sur un
papier de 2013 de stock
c'est un de maurice et antiquités dans
mon jury thèse est donc tout cet arsenal
se poser la question des grandes données
mais jamais de la grande dimension donc
les données et donc n 6 n c'est le
nombre de données pensé m c'est le
nombre de vidéos où j'ai pas de nom de
le nombre de personnes que vous avez en
france et 60 millions la dimension c'est
le nombre de données collectées par
personne les deux si on regarde les
données de l'insee
on peut avoir un gros tableau de alessi
enfin une enquête sur un million de
français c'est déjà beaucoup
rarement ce tableau va avoir plus de dix
colonnes n égale à 1 million d égale à
10 et donc s'y pique mans les outils de
la statistique robuste souci est du
grand n
quand on dit big data pour eux c'est dit
que grand m mais rarement de grandes
haies et donc quand on trouve un outil
qui me dont la complexité dans le cou ne
grandit pas avec n
on est content mais si grand direct des
on sait que tu es c'est une constante
ces deux ou trois donc donc ce papier de
maurice et reliques je mentionnais il
disait à la fin donc leur algorithme
tourné en puissance des aidants qu'à la
fin ils disaient nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est que les gens se mettent
d'accord sur un point dans le plan ou un
plat en point dans l'espace
tridimensionnel donc ça va n au carré où
elle occupe ça va sauf que aujourd'hui
les vidéos youtube ne venons pas cdc des
entrées qui ont un million de dimension
voire plus en faire un million fois
pourquoi chaque frame donc c'est que
c'est des égale à 1 milliard donc une
puissance un milliard c'est juste pas
possible et en fait c'est que c'est que
depuis 2016 qu'il ya une série de percer
en statistiques robuste
je peux mentionner la thèse de giacobbe
steingart soutenu en 2018 croix où la
thèse de jerry lee om haïti est soutenue
même année où la thèse il ya deux
semaines et il ya pas mal de regards un
intérêt pour la statistique robuste où
on essaye d'être linéaire hand et aussi
donc on essaye de ne pas de ne pas trop
dépendre de la dimension et il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire c'est c'est
donc pour thématique les mathématiciens
dans l'audience quand on dit éthique de
l'ia robustesse de l'ia c'est pas juste
en acceptant dans sa tête je viens de ce
mag rendent à avoir que les thématiques
éthique etc sont des thématiques de
sciences molles philosophie sous-entendu
sciences molles et philosophie ça peut
pas être techniquement très difficile en
maths parfaitement aujourd'hui rendre
les ia robuste j'en parle même pas de
les rendre éthique juste les rendent
robuste face face à des données par
exemple et autres liars est
mathématiquement très très difficile
il ya des problèmes ouverts très
important très compliquée à résoudre et
il ya ce que depuis 2016 que la
communauté s'est réveillé à fait
maintenant il faudrait revenir à la
statistique robuste et regarder les
dépendances de rappeler encore contexte
donc ça vient en fait d'un changement
des algorithmes n'utilise qui sont
beaucoup plus de l'apprentissage et qui
exploite donc des grandes dimensions et
du coup ils prennent des camps dimension
c'est que des variables de thé c'est
vraiment très très grande union moyart
en fait c'est tellement problématique
que stéphane may la danse en cours à au
collège de france toute une année
portait le titre
l'apprentissage face à la malédiction de
la grande dimension c'est suffisamment
important pour mobiliser un cours d'une
année aux collections italiennes mais
ouais moi même problème sur un autre
problème qui
la théorie du choix social commence on y
met d'accord sur quelque chose quand on
a des avis divers et variés et à ma
connaissance encore aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya un paquet de 2018 qui crée un
petit peu au-delà mais ils ont jusqu'à
2018 mais en très grande partie encore
aujourd'hui les gens qui réfléchissent à
la théorie du choix social dont on a
plusieurs personnes qui veulent se
mettre d'accord et du coup on fait un
scrutin on vote pour le premier tour
d'accord du vote qui sont étudiées sont
des votes où le nombre de possibilités
est très faible et par vaux 500 le
nombre de votants peut être grand nombre
de possibilités petit de possibilités et
moti alors techniquement on cherche
quand même avoir des algorithmes qui
sont à dire polynomiale ans le nombre de
possibilités
si on a mille possibilités techniquement
ça pourrait être possible d'appliquer
pendant que les scouts en course et
randomisés pour ceux qui quittent ils
suivent un peu ma chaîne et qui savent
de quoi je parle
pareil le jugement majoritaire tout
simplement h avec avec 1000 options ça
prend un peu de temps mais techniquement
ça premier marché par contre ce sur quoi
on aimerait se mettre d'accord dans des
problèmes éthiques
passez pas mille option étant s'imagine
programmé code moral du mia ou un texte
de loi 2 milliards d'autres c'est ce
même pas des milliards ces biscuits sens
me le disent quand le couple c'est un
nombre allemand exponentielle qui est
beaucoup plus grand et là du coup on a
besoin d'algorithmes dont le temps de
calcul sera soulignée
c'est plus rapide que le nombre de
demandes des tas de qu'elle veut bien
plus petit que le nombre de possibilités
et donc ça a dû lui demander technique
radicalement différente et à ma
connaissance aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
bonne recharge théorie du choix social
souligne encore un domaine de recherche
inspiré par des questions d'éthique
d'algorithmique qui sont aussi juste
fantastique
d'un point de vue recherche célébrant
des questions profondes
il ya énormément de direction possible
hilarant de théorèmes approuvé notre
livre du couple présente pas mal de ces
problèmes divers contextes il m'a
vraiment pas mal qu'on essaie de mettre
en avant ce que je pense aussi un des
objectifs communs non niveau c'est ton
courage est vraiment les gens à se dire
ah tiens ça ça se rendre intéressant je
remarque que j'aimerais creuser est ce
possible
isaïe creuser même si les chercher là
bas a dirigé la recherche mars à 6 et
des étudiantes être redirigé un peu leur
cursus versa après ouais donc je pense
que oui un autre aspect quand leurs
avants avant d'en créer vraiment dans le
vif du sujet du livre
donc on a parlé avant qu'on va parler
des dégâts des victimes désir en a vu
une chine n'a jugé utile de prendre un
peu de recul sur la notion d'information
donc on en venir le chapitre iii l'année
sur les problèmes des lianes oui oui en
fait dans quoi on allait revenir sur le
problème de la tension
oui attention bien divaguer je pense que
ça va les suivre dans ce truc parce
qu'on est un peu tous les deux du genre
à pas mal divaguer mais tu peux donc des
problèmes que l'on voit ce mois donc on
parlait d'une intention des programmeurs
et beaucoup de gens pensent que c'est
une partie pleine et c'est une partie du
problème mais de façon plus générale en
fait l'un des gros problème c'est que on
a accepté souvent de faire des intérêts
des algorithmes dirigé par d autres
fonctions objectif parce qu'on pensait
que la fonction d'objectifs n'était pas
méchante en pointe et elle est donc l'un
de ses objectifs par exemple qui est le
sont plus fréquents et d'algorithmes et
plus déployé aujourd'hui c'est une fête
de maximiser la tension le typiquement
l'algorithme de youtube va vouloir que
les utilisateurs youtube reste sur
plateforme l'algorithme de facebook
pareil tu pleures pareil instagram
timber pas mal d'exemples d'algorithmes
en fait on s'est essayé au business
model bien sûr mais les algorithmes en
tant que tels ils sont pas là pour
maximiser du profit si on y réfléchit en
ce qu'elle chantait ses algorithmes le
fond c'est vraiment puissent maximiser
la tension et ça c'est une tendance
beaucoup plus général qui va au delà des
algorithmes si on réfléchit à pas mal de
choses dans nos sociétés par exemple
youtube heures par exemple un média par
exemple un mouvement politique plein
plein de choses comme ça l'objectif
premier
pas forcément 1er mai et qui finissent
par se donner c'est souvent maximisation
de la tension nombre de personnes
typiquement qui vont être qu'ils ont
écouté leurs messages
donc on a rentré un peu dans cette
économie où la tension est de plus en
plus une ressource rare et s'est du coup
de plus en plus la ressource sur lequel
il ya un vrai bras bataille pour que
pour les personnes qui pourraient dire
maintenant mais en fait ce dont ils
parlent existait avant les réseaux
sociaux avoir internet avant les
algorithmes de recommandation oui les
journalistes très tôt dans l'histoire du
journalisme en a compris qu'il fallait
appliquer en sont des exemples de ce
qu'on appelle la presse jaune après
jones est la forme la plus la forme la
plus la forme la plus péjoratif du
journaliste qui cherche à attirer
l'attention par un clic clic pas
racoleur voilà la notion de titres
racoleurs ça existe depuis très très
longtemps dans le journalisme
mais ce qui a changé aujourd'hui c'est
que on a des outils de traitement de
l'information automatisée
ces algorithmes ce qu'on a plaisir dans
ce livre qui pour la première fois de
l'histoire permettent un ciblage massif
et personnalisé avant voilà si on
voulait être massif fallait dire la même
chose à tout le monde donc penser à la
propagande d'un grand empire une grande
dictature
on va à placarder le même message sur
tous les murs donc je pars si on pense à
la guerre froide
partout en urss vous avez des gros
message anti américains ou anti
impérialiste et anti capitalistes et
cesser les mêmes messages et partout aux
états unis vous auriez des panneaux sur
la menace menace soviétique ou des spots
publicitaires sur fond de lui sert de
wendy's marque qui se moquer un peu du
fait qu'on n'a pas trop de choix en urss
a donc si on va chez wendy's on a
beaucoup de burgers différents et mais
c'est le même spot publicitaire pour
tout le monde donc si si on voulait être
massif fallait dire la même chose à tout
le monde parce que l'outil de
dissémination de l'information ne
proposait que le broadcast ne proposait
que le squale broadcast en français la
voilà contraste et même être le même
message a souvent tu sais tout ce qu'on
pouvait faire avec la télé et si on
voulait être personnalisé fallait
s'inspirer des sectes religieuses ou des
partis politiques etc est appelée faire
des portes du porte à porte
alors on fait la porte à porte chez
chacun commence à connaître la personne
quand vous appelez comment fait quel
sport etc commencent à connaître les
gens peut-être fait des fiches sur eux
on se renseigne mais ça c'est très lent
comme trop de pro process ça passe pas à
l'échelle il faudrait mobiliser
je sais pas moi 20 millions de personnes
qui font du porte à porte pour balayer
un dixième des états unis et ça prendra
beaucoup de temps et les gens auront
évolué dans leur opinion avant qu'on
puisse savoir quels messages ciblés et
bat aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux
on est à la fois massif et personnalisés
donc on peut donc l'eau sur sur facebook
pendant le brésil la fameuse
six journalistes qui apparaît dans le
documentaire sur canal j k vous
conseille le livre a un devoir et une
des juristes qui a travaillé sur le cas
du brésil montrent que je te dis que
dans la même famille les gens ne verront
pas les mêmes spot publicitaire
politique d'accord avant dans les années
jusqu'aux années 2000
si vous viviez dans le même foyer vous
auriez vu les mêmes spots publicitaires
pour les partis politiques
aujourd'hui je peux acheter un spot qui
va te parler de football parce que je
sais que tu aimes le foot est atteint à
temps par attend à tes parents montrer
autre chose mais en fait pour avoir
votre même vote etc
en fait donc il ya quasiment autant de
spots autant de manières de personnes
papa autour de spots presque mais autant
de fil d'actualité que d'individus donc
les fils d'actualités sur un réseau
social individualisé
mais en même temps on peut faire ça de
manière massive parce qu'un coup deux et
ça change beaucoup
en fait ça ça fait que les raisonnements
concise et sur la presse jaune sur le
racolage etc ne s'applique plus
aujourd'hui puisqu'il faut ajouter le
côté massif plus personnalisés donc si
on maximise la tension de manière
massive et maxime personnalisés on aura
des effets secondaires qu'on n'observait
pas avec la presse joe bracco l'adjoint
l'esstic du 20e siècle
ouais c'est l'aspect
ultrapersonnalisation c'est vraiment des
points très importants pour pas mal
d'aspects donc par exemple un autre truc
je remarque souvent quand je parle de
youtube où j'en sais que chacun va
décrire son expérience de youtube une
autre chacune de nos expériences n'est
absolument pas représentative de tout ce
qui se passe sur youtube parce que
youtube est ultra personnalisés mes
recommandations d'une vidéo n'ont rien à
voir dans cette vidéo d'un autre essai
du coup très difficile à cause de cette
personnalisation de savoir ce qui se
passe sur youtube en général d'ailleurs
les gens ont toujours leurs logiciels
télévision dans la tête sans les gens me
posent souvent des questions sur les
réseaux sociaux avec un logiciel
télévision mais t'as pas vu ça sur
facebook il te parle d'une actualité
abcd c'est entendu mais t'as pas vu
c'était sur facebook j'ai déjà cette
remarque en fait surtout aux débuts de
facebook surtout de nos générations qui
ont vu la télé avant qu on a beaucoup de
réflexes télé n'a pas vu ça à la télé
sous-entendu hier soir on était tous
deux face à la télé on va garder la même
chose bah non ça marche pas oublier que
je peux pas te dire t'as pas vu que ça
se fait ou ce que ce qui s'affiche et
chez moi là c'est parti du coup ça rend
l'objet facebook ou extrêmement
compliqué à étudier oui c'est à dire
qu'il ya sont beaucoup de parties de
tubes qui sont fantastiques
bon moi j'adore une actualité sur
youtube
mais il ya aussi sont départis de
youtube qui sont absolument horrible et
puis ça c'est un autre des trucs dans le
livre à travers le livre comme tu l'as
dit on encourage beaucoup des gens à
s'intéresser à beaucoup de problèmes
autour des algorithmes est un des traits
qui on défend beaucoup c'est le fait que
étudier ce qui se passe sur youtube
c'est peut-être le plus bel objet de
recherche en sociologie qui existe kaya
ils n'ont rien comprendre youtube d'un
point de vue sociologique c'est
comprendre énormément de choses
finalement beaucoup plus que viale et
probablement que via deux canaux
traditionnels
du coup je me jean prix de faire la pub
pour pour un ami qui s'appelle you are
crime elle d'ailleurs qui qui a beaucoup
étudié youtube ou fonction cambiasso
qu'il était intervenu dans ce podcast
qui étudient youtube et il cherche à
comprendre youtube
malheureusement c'est un peu compliqué
parce que youtube est très fermé c'est
un peu compliqué d'avoir des données sur
youtube et c'est même un peu frustrant
je tire à condition que fuient interview
par des sociologues et les informations
les plus fascinantes que j'ai à partager
son des informations sur mes propres
données de michel de particules 200 vols
et c'est un petit peu peut-être
compliqué du convoi de devoir passer par
mois pour avoir accès à des données qui
sont très intéressants entendu
sociologique
un autre truc que c'est que je voulais
dire sur l'ultra personnalisation c'est
que ça m'arrivait aussi d'avoir des
discussions parfois un peu un peu oublié
on va dire parfois sur le côté très gras
femmes américain on va dire du coup
google et américains est inverse en
europe on a d'autres valeurs défend des
valeurs de l'europe hors france coco
vraiment ce discours est un petit peu
trop extrême dans certains même s'il y
avait du vrai là-dedans de notamment de
des droits qu'il ya tout ça mais bon
sans rentrer dans les détails ce qui est
largement possible grâce à une trappe
personnalisation c'est aussi simplement
d'implémenter des valeurs européennes en
europe
on pourrait très bien avoir une il ya
beaucoup plus dont les valeurs morales
selon eux cherche à les implanter ont
des particularités locales
du coup on fait tous partie n'a pas
besoin d'avoir une mois le programme et
surtout plaisir et je pense que ça ça
permet d'avoir beaucoup plus de richesse
dont la réflexion autour du cou c'est en
tout cas c'est des champs de recherche
qui viendraient voir beaucoup plus haut
à dresser peut-être juste fait même si
je sais pas je pense que c'est pas ça
fait pas trop sens de suivre les
chapitres linéaire mans juste en parlant
de l'ultra personnalisation on en a
mentionné le cas du truc
le cas de six affiches chez toi sur
facebook savent pas dire que cette
affiche est moins sur facebook même si
on avait les mêmes amis exactement lé
même groupe mais en fait c'est pareil
pour la régulation
un an plus tard dans le livre on va
parler du contraintes sur les
contraintes de lien et en fait il est
souvent aujourd'hui dans les débats
peut-être bien qu'on en parle très tôt
dans le podcast la tentation de réguler
en fait c'est bien dribbler il faut il
faut réguler on dit pas que au contraire
il faut absolument et urgemment réguler
beaucoup d'aspects des algorithmes
influence sur la société
mais la manière de réguler le logiciel
tout comme le logiciel télévision
broadcast ne marche plus logiciel
régulation va beaucoup se bat beaucoup
se heurter à la spécificité de la
personnalisation
parce que manon d'habitude comme en
régulant réguler par exemple à elle une
campagne électorale
quand on a un soupçon sur une campagne
électorale
on va faire un passage en revue des
publicités des spots publicitaires temps
de parole etc
est ce que les médias ont respecté les
temps de parole est ce que tu dis est ce
que ceci est ce que cela est surtout en
tout audit et rapidement aujourd'hui ce
qu'on dit et ce qui s'est affichée chez
60 millions de français je pense pas et
le temps pour fès audit fait le deuxième
quinquennat on va déjà vu si on si on a
un doute par exemple sur les élections
de 2000 jeu peu avant 21 22 22
si on a un doute sur les élections en
2022 et qu'on veut faire un audit
exhaustif de la campagne politique sur
les réseaux sociaux
si on veut vraiment à la faire à
l'ancienne et que de manière exhaustive
puisque de manière exhaustive à
l'ancienne on va regarder tous les
tracts sauf que y'en a pas un milliard
de tracts une centaine centaines de
tracts allée des spécificités par villes
les campagnes d'affichage on va passer
en revue les tracts laisse les posters
etc
les passages les spots radio les spots
télé en a fait le tour aujourd'hui si on
veut faire la même logique il faudrait
review est ce que facebook a affiché à
60 millions de francs soit 140 millions
d'électeurs aux hydroliennes français en
âge de vote
et ça ça ne s'est juste pas faisable et
donc il faut repenser même la notion de
régulation et qu'est-ce qu'on régule sur
l'objectif c'est maintenant presque en
réguler la maximisation de l'intention
est ce qu'on régule donc les mêmes
maîtres même il ya donc on a parlé des
challenges techniques mathématiques il
ya des challenges techniques juridiques
et techniques mais c'est pas pas et
pathétique aussi des challenges
techniques juridiques le lieu droit est
à repenser si on peut faire la pub d'un
livre seroul soit un flat world jillian
banfield qui est à ma connaissance une
une des juristes fin c'est une jolie
c'est une académicienne du droit cet
économiste mais aussi m
c'est une académicienne du droit qui
s'intéresse beaucoup à la notion de
régulation et dans son bouquin je n'ai
pas encore lu les détails du point que
j'ai vu des extraits et un papier
académique où est présenté le bouquin et
l'introduit ce type de nouveaux
paradigmes en fait de la régulation pour
s'adapter pour passer à l'échelle non
c'était la ccct à orly tout doux dans le
versement de 40 et puis surtout sur ces
questions de régulation il ya énormément
de fausse bonne idée
je pense que c'est c'est une idée des
jeux gouro des principes assez vague et
le fait d'insister beaucoup sur ces
principes assez vague risque d'orienter
la discussion ouvert vers des choses qui
sont pas efficaces et qui peuvent même
être contre-productif une chance que
c'est un des appels aussi ils ont fait
beaucoup dans ce chapitre on parle de la
régulation des naissances artificielle
que des algorithmes c'est que c'est
vraiment une tâche très difficile et que
si on veut faire ça de manière
précipitée
c'est assez probablement fait qu'on ait
des trucs qu'ils soient contre-productif
et du coup c'est super important de
d'abord bien réfléchir de balorre
d'ailleurs d'abord bien s'informer à ces
questions et c'est un des aspects assez
difficile explique moi si vous voulez
mieux réfléchir à comment réguler les
algorithmes peut-être au hasard
informez-vous auprès d'un nouveau livre
qui ne sortira qui est pas mal
je prends d'une autre nature donc ça
c'est clairement un des aspects vraiment
difficile tant qu'on est assurée sur
l'aspect droit j'ai eu aussi l'occasion
pas mal de
plusieurs reprises de parler avec des
juristes des ses poèmes de régulation
est clairement une des grosse difficulté
c'est que le droit jusque là est
beaucoup plus dans la réaction pas que
le droit mais globalement en particulier
du droit les gens sont beaucoup plus
dans la réaction
on a développé des outils ou les à
déployer fonds ont été entreprises ont
déployé ou même gouvernement la déployer
et seulement 57 10 ans plus tard on se
rend compte que ça pose des problèmes et
donc commencé à chercher à légiférer et
l'appareil ça prend du temps et ça c'est
important que ça prend du temps si on
fait ça de façon précipitée s'appelle
dangereux mais du coup forcément ça
prend du temps
du coup ça prend encore 5 ans et qu'au
final on aime on a une loi qui qui qui
sort mais qui sort voie d une décennie
après le problème en question et qui a
adapté à l'époque de ce problème
un des aspects nos propriétés
importantes des algorithmes qu'on
développe aujourd'hui c'est que le
progrès en algorithmique ce qu'on est
capable de faire des algorithmes
évoluent extrêmement vite à une vraie
vitesse du progrès qui est vraiment
rapide faire en cinq ans des tas de
l'art du monde en informatique ou ce qui
est déployée dans pas des entreprises du
numérique sans joue beaucoup que du coup
dérégulation qui s'adapte à une
technologie qui sort instant t peuvent
être complètement dépassés être
contreproductive ou complètement
inadéquate cinq ans plus tard et donc
c'est un des autres aux appels du livre
c'est au lieu de chercher à être
constamment dans la réaction
c'est devenu son autre critique étant de
la vitesse du progrès de chercher à une
beaucoup plus dans this est maintenant
dans l'anticipation et du coup dans la
projection et dans une prédiction et ça
amène un autre particulier d'un autre
aspect sportif sait que faire des
prédictions sur le futur c'est pas
facile surtout c'est surtout mon général
mais surtout en ce moment
vu la vitesse du progrès
c'est très difficile d'imaginer ce que
sera ce que seront les algorithmes les
plus influents du 6 5 ans d'ici dix ans
mais en plus malheureusement c'est pas
toujours bien reçus la manière dont près
des choses donc oui on encourage à la
fois csn projeter dans le futur mais
sachant toutes les erreurs de
prédictions on va faire inimitable mans
c'est super important d'être ultra
modeste d'envisager plutôt de [ __ ]
plusieurs scénarios possibles de mettre
des probabilités en fait un langage
probabiliste sur le futur est absolument
pas dire ça ça ne leur a jamais et ça ça
arrivera toujours on sait pas grand
chose du futur c'est important d'avoir
un peu cette zone d'incertitude je
reviens sur attention
enfin on n'est pas très bien en quoi ne
pas dit vas y est donc le gros point de
ses algorithmes qui maximise la tension
ce qui est critique à voir c'est un des
aspects importants c'est du livre c'est
que le gros problème des algorithmes qui
maximise attention c'est pas tant la
tension a même objectif lui-même ses
puces les effets secondaires de cette
fonction d'objectifs est vraiment une
des notions c'est une notion à retenir
du livre je pense plus quand ils ont
sorti ciel puisque puisque woods chose
avec son livre elle fait surprendre
c'est la notion d'effet secondaire
parce que la vraie raison pour laquelle
c'est difficile pour des développeurs de
randers algorithmes bénéfiques ou sait
même pas leurs propres intentions
c'est anticiper les effets secondaires
de l'algorithme qui viennent de
programmer et de et de déployer et ça ça
vient du fait que les algorithmes
d'aujourd'hui ils sont déployés à des
échelles qui me dépasse
interagir avec un milliard d'individus
c'est un truc inimaginable points samedi
et six environnements sont
incroyablement complexe dans cet
environnement dans l'écosystème youtube
il ya tellement de gens différents que
pour un service est très difficile
imaginez tout ce qu'il peut se passer
et du coup c'est très peu c'est très
difficile d'imaginer quels sont les
effets secondaires d'un changement de
cette année au rythme aussi qu'au
changement cet algorithme pensé faire un
truc bien en fait l'algorithme va
favoriser certains trucs entre certaines
personnes puis ces personnes vont réagir
d'une certaine manière qu'ils vont
utiliser la plateforme différemment et
potentiellement ça peut conduire à des
choses ce n'est absolument pas prévu
vous par l'exemple de facebook
oui ça fait par exemple un exemple quand
site dans le livre c'est une hypothèse
donc malheureusement pareil en fait pour
la vérifier il faut aller creuser à
l'intérieur de facebook il ya eu il ya
les skis et ski ski et ski ce qui est
certain ce qui est reconnu c'est que il
ya à peu près deux ans que patron de
facebook du cauberg il a annoncé qu' on
voudrait doter facebook d'une mission
sociale passe quand je fais le tour des
états unis je trouve que les gens il ya
certaines souffrances sociales je vais
parler aux pasteurs du coin il va me
dire que quand les usines ferment je me
retrouve à faire des thérapies de couple
les gens ce sens plus connectés avec
leurs communautés et donc partant
partant de ce qui est vraisemblablement
une très très bonne intention n'est pas
du tout en question les intentions de
facebook sur ce coup là il a été décidé
de favoriser les postes venant de
venons de vos proches sens familiale
géographique
c'est un exemple on reprend du mémoire
mémoire de marianne tighanimine sur
l'affaiblissement des plateformes dans
l'affaiblissement des corps
intermédiaires par les plateformes elle
regarde le cas des journalistes
les syndicats français pendant la crise
dit les jeunes et donc ccsl en fait
qu'il y avait alerté notre attention
fait qui a attiré notre attention sur
sur cet exemple c'est un bel exemple de
d'effets secondaires imprévisibles donc
il ya une intention d'en camp l'enfer
est pavé de bonnes intentions
une intention qui est vraisemblable très
bonne reconnecter les gens avec leur
voisinage géographique et sociale donc
on va donner un score élevé au poste de
votre voisin donc si votre voisin pose
quelque chose on va plus probablement
vous le montrer que si coca cola impose
quelque chose sur sa page donc si vous
êtes abonnés à la page de coca cola et à
la poche des lapins et vous êtes ami
avec votre voisin jusqu'à avant ce
changement il n'était pas rare que là le
poste de foot coca cola s'affiche
beaucoup chez vous et que vous raté
toutes les actualités de votre voisin
après vous le rencontrez au supermarché
bonjour ça va j'ai eu un garçon ah bon
mais je les a lancés sur facebook
je n'ai pas vu voilà merci pour
reprendre le pour reprendre l'exemple de
tout à l'heure de 7 et sur facebook donc
faire un peu de spéculation donc
imaginez vous rencontré votre voisin et
puis vous dis voilà du coup annoncé sur
facebook je n'ai pas vu voilà pas
partant de ce constat que ça serait bien
de doter facebook d'une mission sociale
bénéfique
voilà entre le même le titre que
d'autres libre venez donc on veut rendre
sur facebook socialement plus bénéfique
qu'est ce qu'on se dit les pages sont
souvent utilisés par les marques etc
on va aller enfin les d'angré on va donc
baisser leurs scores
et votre voisin de quartier etc on va
augmenter leur score aux grands parents
vos en clé vos cousins etc
ça a l'air très bien ce arrière très
bien en fait ça peut avoir un effet
secondaire à ses bêtes
donc imaginez vous vous êtes abonné à
l'institut pasteur
et quand la page de l'institut pasteur
qui le plus que l'une des plus grandes
autorités médicales en france quand il
s'agit de microbiologie et de votre
voisin qui anti pacs est là et donc les
postes anti-vaccins de votre voisin vous
seront beaucoup plus exposés voire
quasiment les seuls à être exposés pas à
comparer aux postes de l'institut
pasteur qui alerte sur une épidémie de
rougeole ou de voir ailleurs et
varicelle dans la crèche de votre ghana
et donc on est très bien l'efficacité de
l'exposition sinon on n'aura pas à
marcher de la tude donc par exposition
les gens peuvent changer d'avis peuvent
être influencés et ne pas vacciner donc
à un poste dangereux d'un voisin sur le
même sujet que une autorité médicale
comme l'institut pasteur a plus de
chances d'être à fission est donc là là
on a un exemple il un peu spéculatif
mais il parle il parle il partie par le
point de départ c'est quand même une
en fait on sait que facebook a fait un
changement d'algorithme pour favoriser
les voisins et en c et c est reconnue
aussi par his book que ça défavorisés
cédant traite le mémoire de varia
tighanimine les pages des corps
intermédiaires en fait les corps
intermédiaires dans la société c'est
quoi c'est le corps médical le corps
journalistique le corps politique le
corps syndical donc cd cd sorte
d'intermédiaire entre un société le
peuple et le pouvoir ou le savoir donc
moi non savoir je vais puiser chez c'est
vraiment le cnrs donc je suis abonné à
la page du cnrs camp du cnrs dit quelque
chose ça s'affiche chez moi quand un
journaliste donc les journaux par là ils
ont des pages alors quand je dis pas je
sens de facebook il ya ceux qui sont pas
très habitués y avait profité il ya les
pages
quel profil de l'ennemi est longue mais
à la page 5 for all
la page 5 c'est une page le profil d'un
grand que c'est un profil donc donc
suite à ce changement d'algorithme
lenguin rank sera favorisée dans mon
fils parce que on habite tous les deux
en suisse
conte et collègues et la science forum
va être défavorisées puisque c'est une
page
évidemment ça c'est un truc que j'ai
observé personnellement il sonne son
rôle dans le manga est témoin aux
commandes et du coup si beaucoup moins
centré sur facebook ouais donc les pages
ben en fait qu'ils utilisent les pages
les journalistes effets secondaires
votre voisin qui propagent de fausses
informations a plus de chance de vous
atteindre que le meilleur travail
journalistique factuel et honnête qui
puisse être affiché sur une page d'un
journal le monde libération le figaro
prenez ce que vous votre journal préféré
donc voilà c'est un exemple de d'effets
secondaires qui part d'une bonne
intention la bonne intention c'était
vous reconnecter avec votre quartier
votre ou vos cousins et vos
grands-parents effets secondaires parce
que le fil d'actualités finish on peut
pas vous affichez un milliard de choses
il faut vous affichez faut faire une
sélection
il ya plein de postes qui arrivent il
faut faire un tri ce que quelqu'un peut
dire mais pourquoi vous ne pas afficher
les deux à la place la bla c'est fini on
va dire il ya que la tension voilà la
tension s'est de nouveau pétrole comme
tu disais dans une interview la tension
est limité il faut choisir entre
instituts pasteur et votre voisin
quartier le voisin quartier passera
d'abord alors début 2019
quasiment toutes les plateformes ont
pris conscience à sur le sujet on parle
beaucoup du des vaccins va clairement
que ça sur le sujet des vaccins début
quasiment toutes les plateformes en s'en
prit mesure du problème suite suite au
rapport de l'organisme organismes
mondiale de la santé
donc il y eut des communiqués de la part
de youtube facebook m'interresse twitter
sur des sujets comme le vaccin ou ce
qu'on appelle les fournit medical device
les
il reconnaît les recommandations
médicales douteuses
quasiment toutes les plateformes ont
pris des mesures mais après on a là
encore il ya plein d'autres sujets on
parle aujourd'hui du discours de haine
donc dit comment on va définir comment
prendre des mesures contre les discours
de la haine c'est très compliqué
techniquement puisque excusé à rim elle
d'ailleurs des coûts dans son article
c'est que en fait si je sais que c'est
rendu qu'on sait que quand les gens
cherchent et medicaid changement
climatique sur youtube la plus les
premières vidéos recommandé était
défendu le changement climatique
consensus scientifique
donc ça allait bien si on a un peu plus
loin en fait c'est mon beaucoup moins
bon est en fait si on regarde le total
du nombre de vues en fait c'est pas
terrible c'est 50 50 que les vidéos qui
dénigrent qui dit nalistes qui nie le
changement climatique sont aussi vu
quasiment que pour son prêt moi qui
emporte son prêt que les vidéos qui peu
à peu près scientifique mais après ça
c'est un des points on n'est pas très
flatteur mais un des points encore plus
problématique c'est que ce casque entre
lloris et que les nôtres on cherche des
démos qui sont un peu différents c'est
une pas le terme standard de meetic et
meetic
si on cherche par exemple climate
modifications les détails allez ce qui
ce qui donnait 100 a cédé qu on change
un petit peu la terminologie il faut
bien imaginer que la plupart des gens
qui sont pas experts de ce domaine n'ont
pas tapé le mot du jargon du domaine et
ben en fait on a un nouveau ces
vulnérabilités en fait les c'est
beaucoup plus difficile pour youtube de
gérer tout ça et du coup on a encore pas
mal de venir habiter
enfin tout ça les changera vous dire
aussi à l'exemple de facebook parce que
je crois que c'est un exemple de très
probablement fausse bonne idée et il
correspond s'accroissant finalement pas
mal à ce que beaucoup de gens disent
main pour influences artificielle qui
qui est il faut mettre l'humain au
centre
c'est exactement ça quelques cafés
cherché à mettre l'humain au centre de
facebook
et quand on entend la phrase il faut
mettre au numéro centre c'est très
difficile de se dire c'est pas bon
tellement dire mais oui car il faut
mettre mais là dans ce cas en émettant
l'humain au centre on a eu des effets
secondaires qui était vraiment pas
facile à prévoir est là l'erreur c'est
pas l'intention difficulté de prévoir
ses effets secondaires
ouais au maroc on dit que quand la
cigogne veut embrasser son fils on sent
son enfant l'enfant perd un oeil
s'ils gagnent on a un bec l'intention
c'était d'embrasser le gamin mais à
cause du bug le gamin va perdre un oeil
puisque le vexin entraînant des mets et
du coup ça sert mais la tête un autre
mot très important du livre qu'il me
robustement être bénéfique globalement
en fait c'est bien mais on risque alors
pas mal de vulnérabilité embrasser un
bébé avec un bec de cigognes sont hyper
serré c'est ça qui peut ainsi pas juste
souvent il faut que ça soit quasiment
tout le temps et ça ça devient très
difficile prévoir les effets secondaires
ça devient très très difficile et c'est
pour ça que rendre les matières
artificielles bénéfique robustement
bénéfique
c'est vraiment un énorme défi de
recherche il suffira pas de bonne
volonté
c'est pas juste dire à certaines
personnes que il faut vous soyez
bénéfique
c'est vraiment tout un défi de recherche
je pense qu'on est tout à fait très
d'accord pour dire que youtube facebook
google tout ça nous n'arriverons pas
seul il ya besoin de meilleurs
chercheurs au monde et peut-être même de
milliers dizaine de minutes et de
centaines de milliers de chercheurs au
monde
qui attaquent ce problème sous
différents angles avec leurs différentes
expertises pour relever ce fabuleux défi
en hôtel en sortir au restaurant
bénéfique donc ouais donc pour en
revenir à la tension vraiment le prime
de la tension c'est pas tellement
l'objectif en tant que tel c'est les
effets secondaires de cet objectif et ça
c'est quelque chose assez récurrent je
pense donc pas mal d'objectifs qu'on se
donne maximiser pib par exemple ça peut
conduire à des effets secondaires qui
peuvent être très néfaste est plus
néfaste que ce qu'on attend en
maximisant cet objectif donc ça c'est ça
c'est ça un petit peu l'attraction du
vip alors là ne parle pas mal des
problèmes et dont le livre papin les
premiers parce que c'est ce qui
interpelle le plus mais j'aimerais bien
aussi parler un peu des les opportunités
parce que c'est pas juste quelque chose
ne va pas c'est aussi plein de trucs
qu'on pourra faire si les idées
intelligence artificielle été conçu en
vue sont bénéfiques et qu'on peut pas
faire aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont pas
conçus de cette manière moi mon exemple
le préféré du c'est le problème des
santé mentale parce que pense que si on
réfléchit un peu si on et utilitariste
clairement mais pas besoin d'être utile
risque clairement un des plus grands
problèmes de 2 qui touche le plus de
gens aujourd'hui c'est pas tous les
problèmes de sentiment de solitude de se
pas se sentir valorisé de dépressions
suicides et et ça c'est des preuves qui
sont dans nos sociétés extrêmement
difficiles à corriger et c'est un truc
que tu vas parler du couple après mais
ça avoir vraiment aux problèmes d'accès
à l'information sur les différents
individus peut pas diagnostiquer client
quelqu'un si on n'a aucune donnée sur
cet individu
il est très coûteux de chercher les gens
et du coup ça c'est sa pop sa part à ces
problématiques mais un peu le côté
positif finalement d'avoir tous ces
systèmes de recommandation
qui suivent des milliards de personnes
c'est qu'on a un accès à énormément de
données sur chacune des personnes qui
pourra permettre ce genre de diagnostic
dont il ya déjà des études pendant de
facebook qui avait été par donc une
corrélation très marquée entre la
manière dont les gens scroll l'heure
nous fit sur sur facebook et le fait
qu'il soit ensuite diagnostiqués en
dépression par un psychiatre
et le truc c'est que psychiatre peut
avoir un certain nombre d'occasions mais
ça ce n'est pas très bien à l'échelle
alors qu'avec avec facebook qui avec
youtube on pourrait diagnostiquer des
centaines de millions de cadeaux gens
qui sont dans des situations de mental
qui pourraient être améliorés cette fois
très haute volée pour pour pour
l'audience tu sûr que c'est très contre
intuitif que tu es en train de dire
parce qu'en fait des candidats santé
mentale réseaux sociaux mise à l'échelle
je comprends parfaitement que que ça
fait ça ça fasse peur et ça fait peur
hier que si ce truc est mal et que tu es
exploiter s'il ya 1 % d'erreurs 9 quand
certains cas ce serait bien on commence
par le ce qui fait le vrai peur là la
vraie peur c'était le cas de 2014 papier
de 2014
quand il ya un papier donc en 2014 des
chercheurs dans des chercheurs de
facebook
les psychologues associée à des
chercheurs chez facebook en 2014 ils ont
fait une expérience sur 600 mille six
cent vingt mille personnes sait rien sur
l'échelle de facebook mais ça chaque
fois que chaque fois que j'ai raconté ça
une fois une audience de de gens
professionnels de la santé mentale
ils ont d'abord ils ont cru que je crois
que je leur ai raconté le papier ils
m'ont pris pour un complotiste je
l'aurais sortie papier le craquant tolba
pied d'oeuvre
le papier sonne comme du complotisme
donc donc il en prit il en choisit six
cent vingt mille personnes sur leurs
utilisateurs et ils ont décidé de tester
comment le
l'humeur change en fonction ce que ce à
quoi on va exposer ses utilisateurs donc
l'humeur peut l'évaluer avec les
messages par exemple peut très bien
faire un écart et 20 cm à l'aller 6 sur
tes messages sur messenger
regardez l'occurrence d'adjectifs
d'adjectifs malheureux etc et de déduire
une variation de numéros ou faire une
estimation ci sera là si on voit que le
nombre de messages de l'adjectif
péjoratif où le nombre d'objectifs
d'adjectifs se référant à la
satisfaction à la frustration à la
tristesse a été multiplié par 20 et on
le voit de manière consistante quand on
fait l'expérience sur six cent mille
personnes
on peut prétendre on peut se peut qu'on
peut commencer à dire qu'on a on a
observé un phénomène
donc ils font l'expérience sur six ans
les personnes il décide pour certains de
leurs affiches et des choses de plus en
plus heureuse et pour d'autres des
choses de plus en plus triste
malheureuse et il regarde effectivement
il ya eu un changement d'humeur positive
pour les premiers négative que positive
pour ceux à qui on a exposé cercle et
des gens écrivaient des postes plus
voilà plus joyeux plus gai et les autres
qui ont été exposés à plus de tristes et
ses écrits d alors ça fait scandale
l'expérience sheryl sandberg a dû
s'excuser
c'est donc c'était publiée dans
proceedings of the national academy of
sciences est un très très bon journal
multidisciplinaire teggour et
psychologie voilà on a en fait les gens
les gens typiquement face à ce type de
papier donc une audience de personnels
professionnels de la santé mentale et
des chercheurs des chercheurs ici au
chul ho l'hôpital universitaire de
lausanne
quand je leur ai raconté sainz est fou
c'est pas possible c'est du complotisme
genre je monte le papier l'abstract we
hope spurs n égale à 620 milles et un
échantillon voilà c'est un tag taille
d'échantillon qui fait kiffer panique
genre à dire la stasi la stasi sous
stéroïdes
eh ben donc en fait voilà donc le papier
a été dense et se sont excusés il en
plus trop publié sur ce type de choses
et j'aurais préféré qu'ils continuent à
publier ce qu'en fait c'est pire puisque
en plus savoir ce qu'ils font j'aurais
préféré qu'ils continuent de publier sur
les expériences de psychologie qui font
mais après il ya le côté éthique bien
entendu personne n'a envie d'être dans
le 300 milles dans le demi échantillons
qui a été exposé à des poses dépressif
puisque ans qu'on est à dire les experts
connaissent très bien ce qu'on appelle
les épidémies de suicide par exemple il
est très connu qu'un suicide dans un
entourage et provoquer d'autres
suscitent en suicide
voilà suicide dans une école peut
provoquer des suicides ces d'autres
d'autres enfants qu'il faut faire très
attention aux épidémies et ben pareil en
fait voilà c'est des expériences qui
peuvent être très dangereuses donc on
n'invite pas du tout à ce que les gens
commencent à s'amuser à faire ceci et
d'expérience
par contre donc là ça c'est côté
flippant dans de ce que tu es en train
de dire donc là où il est expliqué c'est
que commencer que ces outils là peuvent
avoir un effet notable observables sur
des grande proportion de la population
et ce qui ne serait pas immoral de ne
pas pousser ses outils à ne promouvoir
que positif ou un noah ne jamais
promouvoir la vallasse et on n'avance
rien de 2,2 on n'avance rien de
définitif mais juste en lance la
question c'est que ce qu'il ne faut pas
se poser la question de ce qu'est ce
qu'on voudrait que des outils qui
traitent l'information et qui expose
trois milliards d'humains sur terre à
cette information face et 5 une
stratégie souvent que j'enfonce est un
peu fermés yeux j'ai pas envie de savoir
où j'ai pas envie que l'on préfère le
statu quo ou tel quel
mais n'avoir que tant que les choses
frontale qu'elles bain et des contenus
qui sont vraiment dépressif qui sont
promus et qui pousse font des vagues et
probablement pas mal de gens au suicide
alors pourquoi pas que probablement il
ya des cas des quatre épreuves du cac
sur instagram on pas dire de bêtises
mais il ya eu des cas où il était il
était question d'épidémie de suicide par
bien sur instagram a pris les mesures
après etc
mais c'est pas que spéculatifs ce que tu
es en train de dire et il ya un autre
truc c'est que l'expérience de facebook
du coup c'est ça dure une semaine donc
prévu une a vu déjà les offres d'aidé
effet après seulement une semaine ou
alors lors qu'il ya une présentation
quelques joueurs de craig bouthillier
qui est un chercheur google et yahoo et
qui développe son travail sur
l'algorithme qui les développent des
algorithmes pour l'algorithme de youtube
et il a lui montré des applications pour
voir comment les gens ont changé de
comportement et sur youtube et les
effets c'est pas la semaine c'est
plusieurs semaines mais quelques mois il
ya vraiment des effets qui sont
importants une version un peu difficile
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de bruit mais il
ya quand même un effet sur plusieurs
semaines qui l'ont marqué mais comment
important et le prince ne pas motiver la
recherche qui va dans cette direction
alors sauf que ce soit et il a bien fait
mais si on cherche pas mieux comprendre
tout ça passe à côté d'opportunités
énormes et continue des effets
secondaires indésirables provoqués par
ce nts artificielle par ses algorithmes
après juste un point important c'est que
le papier 2014 c'est avec la technologie
de l'époque en puissance et qui luttera
personnel c'était l'âge de pierre en
termes de déploiement des matelas par
des algorithmes de machine learning chez
facebook
ouais ouais ouais t'as rien d'autre
chose d'autre chose c'est que je pense
que pas mal de chercheurs on n'y a par
exemple sous-estiment le degré de
sophistication des algorithmes déjà
déployé aujourd'hui par facebook youtube
et compagnie il ya vraiment en fait sont
réfléchis à tout est quasi totalité des
avancées les plus spectaculaires
récentes en temps domaine des
intelligences artificielles trouve des
applications pour facebook youtube
notamment la recommandation
tout ce qui est par exemple donc naturel
que je processing très tôt dans le
mariage naturel
tout ça c'est utiliser à fond pour
comprendre
est-ce que tel poste facebook est plutôt
heureux malheureux est ce que il
correspond à son centre d'intérêt ou pas
on parle de moi j'ai pas trop entrer
dans les détails même chose ce n'est pas
sûr sur youtube les vidéos seront
sous-titrés automatiquement surtout et
vidéos importante youtube cherche à les
comprendre manière et tout ce qui est en
reconnaissance d'image à chaque fois
qu'une image et partager sur facebook
youtube c'est les vidéos points d'image
tout ça c'est appliquer et à sa plein
d'applications comprendre les
utilisateurs à partir de leurs histoires
historiques de ce qu'ils ont liké de ce
qu'ils ont paniqué bah c'est vraiment
énorme tout ce qu'il ya à faire et ceux
ci des quantités de données absolument
monstrueuse que dit souvent qu'on ne
peut pas faire de machine learning s'en
ressent données complet c'est pas un
problème pour reste un problème mais
parce qu'avoir des données de qualité
mais facebook et youtube
largement de quoi faire des dons va donc
c'est donc là on a parlé pas mal de 2
attention je sais pas s'il ya un truc
que j'ai oublié de dire sur la tension
mais voilà un truc sur lequel voulait
insister c'est que la tension
l'adduction moyens l'addiction et peuple
un effet secondaire on parle de beaucoup
d'effets secondaires qui sont
préoccupants
un des trucs qui me préoccupe le plus
moi c'est plus l'augmentation des films
de la colère l'énervement d'appareil a
expliqué typiquement augmentation la
colorisation tout ça ça favorise pas les
coordinations la violence et tout ça est
ce que je voulais dire c'est que si on
se replace il ya 15 ans et qu'on m'avait
demandé de travailler sur la gouaille
sur un de ces algorithmes en disant qu'
on développe ses algorithmes pour
proposer aux gens ce sur quoi ils
veulent cliquer parce que c'était
finalement ça qu'ils font ces
algorithmes et j'aurais pas trouvé ça du
tout fin sera posé aucun problème
éthique ça paraît très même quelque
chose de positif foisonnant une offre
aux gens ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils
veulent quoi et donc à cette époque il
semblait y avoir aucun problème est
qu'il n'y avait aucune faille être un
petit peu tordu pour dire à ces gens là
non mais ce que vous faites est
complètement scandaleux bon après après
avec le temps ces petites a rendu enfin
on s'est rendu compte que ça favoriser
l'addiction tout ça mais ce sur quoi je
veux insister c'est que l'objectif peut
paraître bien mais ça suffit pas du tout
à garantir qu'ils aient robustement
bénéfique surtout une fois déployée à
ces échelles donc
donc on a parlé de pas mal de choses
peut-être on va peut-être passer au
chapitre iv non jeudi en soirée pendante
même parle un petit chapitre 6 2 contre
[Musique]
webster en fait on a parlé de
l'addiction l'attention voilà formation
je vois ce qui est peut-être on a déjà
bien couverts le chapitre crabe dans
l'ancien probablement mais ouais mais
juste voilà peut-être juste rapidement
en fait dans le cadre de livres en fait
c'est à un moment à un moment très très
au début du début premier quart du livre
à la fin du premier quart du livre on a
jugé utile de prendre un peu de recul on
parle d'intelligence artificielle des
algorithmes de la technologie de youtube
de facebook n'apparaîtraient ça paraît
très restreint comme cadres comme comme
comme souci de nuire c'est pas sa porte
sur un aspect très restreint notre vie
et dans le chapitre iv
on a jugé utile de prendre un peu de
recul et regarder en fait c'est quoi
l'enjeu aujourd'hui avec lui par des
nouvelles technologies qu'est ce qui a
changé dans notre société et il se
trouve que on est en train de changer
l'aspect le plus fondamental de notre
société
qu'est ce qui nous définit en tant
qu'humain en tant que société c'est
notre manière de traiter l'information
et de transmettre l'information et même
avant même avant d'aller avant d'aller à
ces aspects un peu pro général si on
regarde juste
on cite une anecdote un pdg d'une grande
entreprise qui disait des formes un peu
le propos c'est disant en substance vous
les geeks de la robotique
vous arrivez à automatiser des grues qui
soulève caxton
mais vous n'arrivez toujours pas à
automatiser le personnel ménagers c'est
bizarre ça paraît impressionnant une
grue qui soulève capstone de manière
automatique sans humain qui intervient
mais en fait faire le ménage c'est
beaucoup plus impressionnant parce qu'en
fait ce qui est difficile dans notre
imagination du ménage c'est pas le poids
des tasses c'est vrai que les passants
100 g c'est rien par rapport à un groupe
qui soulève des charges de plusieurs
tonnes
sur plusieurs centaines de mètres
georges que sur 50 m de hauteur vers un
gratte ciel
mais c'est beaucoup plus important c'est
le chapitre commence par expliquer en
quoi faire le ménage c'est plus
impressionnant que une grue automatique
qui soulève 4 tonnes jusqu'à gratte ciel
parce que le ménage donc c'est un
traitement très complexe de la formation
je regardais chaque tasse où se trouve
chaque tasse et il faut combien même je
fais un robot ménager qui traite le
désordre chez moi il sera pas capable de
traiter un désordre chez toi parce que
quand j'oublie l'état si je les oublie
pas au même endroit que toi et ma maison
n'est pas forcément disposer de la même
manière que la tienne donc on peut pas
faire une grue qui soulèvent ces
informations helmand très pauvre c'est
prendre attache et soulevé déposé
revenir c'est se détache au niveau
informationnel c'est très facile à
automatiser même et les tâches ménagères
c'est c'est un traitement d'informations
très complexe et qui changent d'une
maison à une autre d'une tasse à une
autre d'une cuisine à une autre d'un
jour à l'autre donc mais en fait si on
regarde même plus loin ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les cols bleus les ouvriers
etc
et en attendant sa dette mais quand on
regarde les débats télévisés parlant sur
l'automatisation
on entend souvent dire attention
aujourd'hui l'intelligence artificielle
automatise plus que les cols bleus elle
automatise les cols blancs regardez
l'intelligence artificielle fait du
trading
oh là là maintenant les cols blancs sont
en assez j'ai envie de dire il était
plus facilement pas se ruiner plus
facile d'automatiser entraîneur que
d'automatiser que d'automatiser on
travaille de ménage quand je fais le
ménage chez moi c'est des informations
qui change beaucoup beaucoup de
difficulté à prévoir le désordre qui
aura dans la cuisine
et alors que l'information traitée par
un trader il est très bien près procès c
est les très influent il ya un flux
d'informations il ya un automatisme les
entrées les entrées du trader
aujourd'hui on beaucoup de route il ya
beaucoup de routine c'est un trader fait
limite j'exagère à peine mais limite ça
travail à la chaîne
c'est comme poteau mais si elle
travaille la chaîne c'est facile parce
que le lard où arrivent les crocs vient
du haut en mai le crous sur la roue etc
il ya pas mal de hype et pas mal de
routine déjà établie et si on regarde
aujourd'hui les travail quand
qualifierais de col bleu
mais quand on peine encore à
informatiser fait céder travail purement
informationnel si on regarde aujourd'hui
quasiment aucun col bleu il ya aucun
ouvrier qui est payé pour tirer une
corde de manière répétitive pendant une
journée ça plus quasiment plus aucun col
bleu n'est payé pour les calories qu'ils
crâne dans ces minuscules la majorité
des cols bleus quand on regarde bien
sans en payer pour des calories qui
crament dans leur cerveau donc personnel
de ménage
le personnel qui fait le tri des
marchandises dans un supermarché
il n'est pas payé parce que les
marchandises sont lourdes il va les
mettre sur un chariot ya des dispositifs
de transport et c'est plus on le paye
plus parce qu'il va lire que ce paquet
de chips vallat et que ce paquet de
lessive a ici que cette promotion n'est
plus valide après le 15 novembre et
qu'il faut la renvoyer aux fournisseurs
etc pour penser aux personnels qui
traite un supermarché quasiment aucun
les payer enfin la part de leur salaire
qui va dans leurs muscles est beaucoup
plus faible que la part de salaire qui
va dans leur cerveau et donc voilà c'est
ce qui ce qui fait que ce pdg cancy
pouvons entrer du chapitre est il un peu
tout faux sur l'automatisation c'est que
l'automatisation c'est pas l'enjeu de
l'autre animation c'est pas le poids
la masse ou l'énergie des objets qu'on
va faire bouger c'est les patterns c'est
qui va ou qui va qui va dans quel
endroit et donc c'est la disposition de
la matière c'est pas la matière et
l'énergie mais la disposition de cette
matière après donc voilà on enchaîne sur
emprunts importe de recul sur survenir
sur sa sentence et aux joueurs du plus
gros que si on réfléchit pour des sports
pendant que le 100 m fabrication des
robots qui sont plus rapides que kendall
terre par contre le football c c c ou
l'espoir de prêt qui comme ça avec une
bague c'est beaucoup plus difficile de
créer des robots qui sont beaux bon
assez assez assez sport voyez une partie
qui est vraiment mechanics pas facile
mais il ya aussi un côté international
exemple si on regarde bien le meilleur
joueur de football c'est pas les mains
les plus costauds c'est pas ces mecs qui
ont plus d'un an après les cibles aussi
way capacité d'anticiper pas mal de
choses donc si on prend les meilleurs
joueurs de football du nahd mais si par
exemple bon c'est pas n'est pas meilleur
que les autres parce qu'ils sont
costauds mais c'est très simple c'est
typiquement la capacité à contrôler un
ballon que avec nous par exemple nous
apprend pas mal au foot que bat pour
garder la balle suivre la balle des yeux
et puis la compagnie publique et et tout
ça c'est de l'information très détaillé
et on puisse les mecs est d'autant plus
fort s'il arrive à faire ça en regardant
peu la balle ce qui arrive souvent et
beaucoup beaucoup d'action en fait vous
vous trompez un peu l'autre on essaie de
plus regardez la balle et une anticipé
et donc ça c'est dire qu'un aspect un
peu
bon après c'est une information très
rapide un procès c'est quelqu'un
d'information une autre partie
d'information c'est se placer sur le
terrain stratégie stratégie et tout ça
est carrément si vous lisez beaucoup
sont des articles de football la notion
d'être un joueur bien placé il est
toujours bien placé c'est facile dans
les meilleurs joueurs au monde parfois
le large en partie l'effet rebond
matinal crise sévit toujours bien placé
qui n'est toujours la laitue
montrer sans que le ballon revient vers
lui en fait c'est ce qui s'est placée là
où la balle avec plus de chances
d'arriver quoi et du coup juste ce
travail d'être capable d'anticiper ou
est ce que le jeu va aller et tout ça
c'est vraiment un calcul algorithmics
est vraiment du traitement de
l'information
livrant pas facile pour vite de
rapidement finir avec cette cette
parenthèse importance de l'information
donc en fait en ce plus généralement au
delà du pdg qui se comprenaient pas
pourquoi on automatise des grues la
catho n'est pas des robots ménagers qui
soulève d'état 500 grammes c'est qu'on a
tendance à sous-estimer le rôle de
l'information dans l'histoire dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire humaine dans
les sphères de la vie et donc voilà ce
chapitre prend on prend ce détour pour
l'expliquer et donc le propos le prouve
le livre le livre a parlé de la culture
sorties c'est dedans je éthique de
sécurité dedans juridique mais en fait
que vient de faire l'informatique dans
toute cette histoire là bas
l'informatique c'est sur cette formation
le droit c'est c'est une série de règles
qui régissent la manière avec laquelle
la société traite l'information
transaction c'est de l'information un
service c'est un traitement de
l'information le droit juridique le
droit commercial qui régissent est ce
service et c'est une information sur le
traitement des populations
donc ce que ce qu'on nous ce qu'on
explique un peu dans ce chapitre et au
delà même dans le chapitre 16 un peu et
on va revenir plus tard dessus c'est que
des questions des questions d'éthique
par exemple relève du traitement de
l'information et il est important de
s'équiper avec les outils de la science
du traitement de l'information avec la
science algorithmique pour pouvoir les
aborder et inversement
les algorithmes y siens doivent prendre
la mesure et on pense que les abonnés
mais
d'informaticiens ça on nous enseigne pas
encore suffisamment à prendre la mesure
des enjeux sociaux de notre science que
c'est pas la science de java c++
enfin c'est pas que ça c'est aussi ça
mais c'est ces sciences qui va au delà
de la notion d'ordinateurs qui a un
clavier mais tout procès proto procédé
où il ya traitement d'informations
rentre dans le cadre de l'algorithmique
et je sais pas si on peut enchaîner sur
le chapitre 16 où on peut en parler
d'abord de la feuille de route
parlant de la feuille de route je pense
d'abord attendu 25 a résulté avant ça
joue des vraies dents et jouer je vais
peut-être continuer un peu ces
informations parce que désolé aux dbacks
beaucoup mais des quelques quelques
jours j'avais posté sur twitter une
question si vous deviez transmettant un
message aux générations futures
et elle joint oublier toutes les
sciences quel serait le message
important donc un peu cette citation
célèbre de phénomènes qui disait que
pour lui ça serait l'hypothèse atomiste
vous fait que mon des effets date at
home et du coup du coup vous demandez
les avis d'autres personnes et j'ai été
beaucoup vraiment déçu de voir que dans
les réponses il y avait il y avait une
seule réponse qui relevait du traitement
de l'information qui était la forme
globale mais la plupart des gens s'il ya
un truc important c'est clairement pas
la science de l'information
moi ce que j'aurais aimé beaucoup plus
voir j'ai l'impression que pour ça on
pas mal de belles vidéos et de mes
livres pendant 700 c'est dans cette
direction c'est la forme de baisses d'un
côté et aussi de l'autre côté la machine
de turing ou la séance de l'information
qui si on médite vraiment la chance de
l'information ou la forme de bases ou un
des deux ça suffit je pense que l'on
voit le monde vraiment différemment et
on a beaucoup plus les bons outils pour
faire des sciences parce que c'est
complètement ce quasiment ridicule à
quel point l'informatique a bouleversé
les sciences sont imaginables de faire
la science d'aujourd'hui son
informatique
mais également la pensée algorithmique
la pensée informatique réfléchir en
termes d'information d'où vient
l'information ouvert l'information
comment est traité l'information
c'est absolument indispensable pour
faire de la bonne science c'est pas le
multi c'est pas les outils informatiques
c'est juste la pensée l'informatique
penser à gwatt be point c'est le flou
flux de l'information
ça paraît absolument critique aux
sciences et plus gaulois aux
organisations à l'organisation de la
société et je suis ni avec une situation
de rareté dans le livre qu'il vient le
peut le ps est un moment qui disait
quelque chose comme celui qui contrôle
le flux des données données c'est céline
d'information tu es qui contrôle le flux
des données contrôle le futur non
seulement de l'humanité mais peut-être
d'avis elle même des choses comme ça moi
je pense qu'il ya pas mal raison sur sa
pelouse contre les fumeurs à savoir
pouvoir énorme aujourd'hui et on peut se
poser la question de qui a ce pouvoir
sur le contrôle des flux de
l'information dans le monde actuel je
pense que très clairement
l'algorithme youtube fait large offre
des millions de fois plus que n'importe
quel autre nom
du coup c'est aussi le pourquoi dont
s'intéressent beaucoup à l'intelligence
artificielle aux algorithmes dans un
livre qui parle beaucoup d'éthique aussi
c'est que aujourd'hui la priorité
monétique ou non d'une éthique a
vraiment à voir avec
avec les algorithmes et puis sont
aujourd'hui dépassées a fait le renom
justo oui ou non car je sais c'est trop
c'est trop tentant de rester sur eux
[Rires]
aujourd'hui on est face à un
on appelle ça un branchement de
branchement hong hong et en efface on en
est dans une de ces étapes clés de la
civilisation où la manière de traiter
l'information changent donc si on
revient comme en ont conclu ce chapitre
sans regard de l'histoire la grande
histoire d'avis et un changement de
substrats traitement de l'information
est donc aujourd'hui le sait que c'est
un peu comme l'invention de la parole
par par les premiers pro tour ou donc le
du genre homo je sais pas peut-être
avant homo sapiens probablement d'autres
hominidés parler un peu mais l'invention
de la parole c'était déjà une grande
révolution va externaliser la
communication après l'invention de
l'écriture
et puis l'imprimerie puis l'algèbre
l'ordinateur est aujourd'hui en fait on
est en train d'automatiser comment
programme un ordinateur cessé d'en cas
capture hâtives en invente la parole il
ya j'ai par ailleurs un bon million
d'années si on dit que ça à faire paru
avant homo sapiens puis donc là un
million d'années puis en invente
d'écriture ya à peine quelques
millénaires et beaucoup de proto
écriture mais là une écriture un peu
sophistiqué chez les sumériens livre
pionnier rien cinq millénaires à peu
près aussi militaires cinq millénaires
un million cinq millénaires
puis il a raio rafa lui seul à l'algèbre
a dû attendre quatre millénaires
il ya mille ans donc il ya un million
d'années on a commencé à parler un
million d'années il ya 5000 ans on a
commencé à écrire il ya mille ans on a
commencé à écrire de manière abstraite
comme ça avant on écrivait on écrivait
si spécifique un tel vent de deux
chèvres etc
on a commencé à écrire pas de manière
exacte xy sans spécifier si c'est une
chèvre ou une surface agricole
et puis il ya 400 ans on a commencé à
imprimer donc à faire passer à l'échelle
la reproduction de l'écriture et puis il
ya cent ans après ou 8 ans 80 ans on a
inventé l'ordinateur donc on à
automatiser le traitement de
l'information
mais on programmait encore l'orienteur à
la main et aujourd'hui on est à la
veille de l'automatisation de la
programmation donateurs arrêtez de
programmer l'ordinateur à la main ont
valu on va le laisser se programmer avec
les données mais on peut quand même lui
mettre un objectif sais pas si tu es
prêt on va d'abord dans la notion
d'objectif avant de parler de feuille de
route aux joueurs d'être aujourd'hui le
l'enjeu aujourd'hui est que
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
l'informatique plus luce c'est la méta
informatique pendant pendant les 80
dernières années on avait un ordinateur
et on lui disait explicitement ce qu'il
va faire et donc si ça marchait pas il
suffisait de venir ce qu'on lui a dit de
faire ou si si quelqu'un a fait un
algorithme qu'on juge être magnifique il
suffit de le lire l'algorithme la
bourride faisait au pire des cas des
milliers de lignes on le lisait on le
faisait dire par un comité
aujourd'hui on a vu qu'en peut donner un
ordinateur une fonction objectif
maximiser la tension on le laisse
observer les comportements des humains
sur une plate forme et on le laisse
s'auto programmée de telle sorte à
maximiser la tension est donc une notion
peut-être qu'ils fondamentales avant
d'aller sur la feuille de route c'est la
notion d'objectif et que les ya
aujourd'hui s'en doter de ce qu'on
appelle une fonction d'objectifs par
exemple on a parlé du donc mal attention
on peut parler d'eux a alors la notion
d'objectif elle est valable pour kate ou
toute entité qui traite de l'information
on peut parler de l'objectif de coca
coca cola l'entreprise coca cola c'est
une entité qui traite de l'information
stock de l'information et caetera et qui
agit de telle sorte à maximiser un
objectif qui est la survie de coca cola
et le profit de coca cola
le raisonnement donc le problème de
l'alignement que le livre introduit
s'aligner cette fonction objectif avec
ce qu'on voudrait vouloir pour la
société d'entraidé dans le sens dans ce
sens en parle donc elle a été le
problème de l'alignement qui date
maintenant d'une bonne dizaine d'albums
décennies au moins qui a été introduite
par la communauté qui travaille sur la
sécurité de l'intelligence artificielle
en fait le problème de l'alignement
maintenant il ya dix ans les gens
commençaient à se rendre compte du
problème d'alignement des intelligences
artificielles mais maintenant on
commence à se rendre compte que c'est un
problème qui est très général en fait
qui va au delà de l'algorithme déployés
sur un macbook ou un linux
toute entité qui traite de l'information
de telle sorte à atteindre un objectif
fait face au problème de l'alignement
devrait aligner ses valeurs par rapport
à quelque chose et on devrait se poser
la question est ce que ce seul objectif
à maximiser est aligné avec l'objectif
où il créera des effets secondaires
néfastes et donc je sais pas si tu veux
dire des choses sur la notion d'objectif
mais je pense je pense que c'est pas mal
d'en parler avant d'aller vers la ville
haute
ouais tu es très vite et que 1 des des
hypothèses sur lesquelles on s'appuie
qu'on se livre c'est que les ja vont
fonctionner avec un objectif et même
plus spécifiquement on parle d'eux
s'appelle d'apprentissage pas
renforcement n'ont pas besoin d'entrer
dans les détails et même taille mais bon
il y avait un présage pas forcément
c'est vraiment à voir cette scène c'est
yaki conçu avec hmm pas exactement ce
qu'il sait plus où on lui donne des
ailes un score qu'elle reçoit
régulièrement des scores positifs
négatifs et à chaque fois qu'il reçoit
un score positif à se dire et j'ai fait
en train de bien du coup je vais essayer
d'en avoir plus et 6,6 un score négatif
ou juste un score qui plus bas qu'avant
on veut dire jeudi on avait peut-être
fait quelque chose de pas bien et du
coup il ya vraiment réagir par rapport à
ces récompenses à ce score qu'on me
donne
du coup le point de l'alignement bon en
fait je vais prendre un exemple
aujourd'hui il ya de youtube
l'algorithme youtube
il a comme objectif ce que les gens du
tube appel 12 heures
engadget c'est un énorme mystère de
savoir ce qu'il ya dans ce zoo games
mais bon il ya des trucs sans doute
comme le match tant que les gens passent
à garder youtube android nombre de clics
sur youtube est en fait ce qui se passe
en fait c'est un peu comme si lorsque
l'ombre de deux heures que les gens
passent sur youtube augmente
l'algorithme youtube reçoit une
récompense est en train de dire il faut
que je répète lors de choses
et du coup vraiment le toutou
l'algorithme va être dragués vraiment
conduit par la quête récompense futur
grand alors juste à dire que en fait le
pari que les ja du futur oran et
fonction d'objectifs pour ceux qui ne
sont pas convaincus alors juste un
argument très très très très
[Musique]
terre-à-terre d'encre appelant nous on a
des ordinateurs à les programmes et puis
encore à des programmes on écrit
programme un allié à la main si si les
est en face de moi donner une place s'il
n' est pas en face ne pas donner une
dass sie trucs moches et vert affiche
est ok si c'est rouge affiche et non en
écrit ceci à la ligne à à la main et en
anna turing a remarqué que sa page pas à
l'échelle écrire des programmes à la
main ne passe pas à l'échelle est en
fait il donc il va invoquer un argument
de complexité sauf que nombre de lignes
à écrire juste pour parler français
normal un argument de fass festif c'est
fastidieux
l'argument sait que ça va être
fastidieux de programmer à la main des
choses très intelligentes et donc avec
cet argument peut très bien se
convaincre que malia du futur sera
beaucoup plus probablement beaucoup plus
complexe
puis les algorithmes qui ont écrit à la
main aujourd'hui déjà on écrit beaucoup
déjà fait en donne l'exemple dans le
livre du code source qui a envoyé les
humains sur la lune
on donne on donne l'exemple du code du
code source qui a envoyé les yeux et il
m'a donné un câble pour mettre dans mes
mains pour bad m touché le câble du
micro donc dans plus qu'aux sources qui
a envoyé les humains sur la lune sur la
lune il fait quasiment 1 m 70 la taille
de la programme atteint
d'informaticienne la galette hamilton
qui n'a creed est vraisemblablement
faire des choses beaucoup plus
intelligente calé sur la lune puisque à
lui sur la lune finalement c'est pas
très complexe
ces fusées envoyé atterrir se mettre en
orbite etc
cebu c'est beaucoup moins complexe que
faire ça peut paraître bizarre mais oui
envoyé à envoyer un satellite en orbite
c'est c'est plus facile que automatiser
le ménage de tous les foyers français
allez je rajoute la condition
remédiation douceur à terme de
complexité en termes de caen bien il
faut écrire de lignes de code combien il
faut écrire de lignes de codes à la main
et en 1950 turing idée sympa je pars à
l'échelle écrire à la main c est avec
cet argument il est très facile de se
convaincre qu'on ne va pas programmer
les ja du futur à la main on va les
laisser à prendre de données mais il
faut les guider voilà c'est juste ça il
faut les guides et c'est ce qu'on
appelle fonction du tiff faut leur
donner un sens à ce qu'il faut faire
avec les données ont regardé les données
regardez quand est ce que les gens
restent plus longtemps renforcer ce que
dans les données
vous avez vu qui maximise le temps de
séjour sur la plate forme ça l'objectif
cet argument de turing j'adore et je
pense que c'est vraiment le l'argument
de la science de l'information qui
devrait être beaucoup mieux connue de
tout le monde surtout des choix qui font
d'informatique
ce que c'est fou à quel point il est je
crois qu'ils ont tant de tueries 1950 il
parle
si vous entendez parler du test de
turing probablement quelqu'un vous en a
parlé d'une manière un peu ésotérique et
malheureusement même des célébrités du
machine learning en parle comme si
c'était quelque chose d hôtes eric alors
qu'en fait le papier contient sept
sections une section 7 cette section qui
sent très technique et c'est le
fondement de l'apprentissage machine
c'est pas exotérique du tout ce concept
c'est vraiment une déception c'est pas
exotérique du tout voilà cip est juste
je vais vous à votre machine learning
c'est explique pourquoi sinon ça va
marcher pas ou pas assez sa seule façon
de programmer et à des algorithmes
capables de prouesses comme passer le
test de turing
c'est un article fantastique d'autre
part pas mal dans le livre joue pas mal
de façon générale bref donc les idées
des algorithmes du futur seront sans
doute par apprentissage très
probablement par apprentissage et avec
une fonction objectif qu'est ce qui peut
mal se passer
qu'elles prêtent de fonctionner et il a
bien très découpées avant le avant le
livre en fait les avais tu fais de la
pub mais avait fait un propos d'un
propos pour proposition à la communauté
il avait présenté sa la conférence
triplé à et dans l'association pour la
défense noté jean sarrailh ça lui a fait
faire une bonne balade les volcans et il
a proposé à la communauté donc de la
sécurité qu'il ya une feuille de route
est en fait cette partie du bouquin se
base quasi quasi complètement sur cette
feuille de route donc je pense que c'est
mieux de laisser expliqué enfin donc je
pense que ben ali est vraiment c'est que
c est certes critique de faire en sorte
calcul et du coup les récompenses un
algorithme
de fait en sorte que ce calcul soit soit
vraiment bien fait et qu'il ait pas de
vulnérabilité aussi peu plus possible et
du coup l'observation très simple que je
fais c'est que faut absolument qu'on
réfléchisse à tous tout du coup c'est si
si on a juste une vision un peu
parcellaire la chose on risque d'oublier
des choses c'est important d'avoir une
vision qu'on appelle nt est donc de
l'entrée donnant rappelé tout alors on
va observer les données de l'entr'aide
jusqu'à la prise de décision c'est sympa
vu puisque donc la concurrence plus là
la récompense qui sera donnée donc l
algorithme et du coup tout seul c'est ce
que j'appelle le circuit sans beaucoup
d'innovations à dire et d'idées ensuite
c'est de remarquer que pour que ça
fonctionne bien il faut qu'ils aient des
composants qui sont incontournables
donc là promis deux premiers composants
sait il faut collecter des données on
peut pas calculer des récompenses
adéquate à donner si on ne sait pas ce
qui se passe dans le monde
donc il faut vraiment une collecte de
données et à pas mal de problèmes pour
parler plus en détails autour de tout ça
on va avoir des données c'est une partie
importante
ensuite il faut bien entendu que les
données collectées
c'est un échantillon probablement biaisé
et très incomplet en tout cas de tout ce
qui se passe dans le monde
du coup faction pas croire directement
les données il faut faire de l'inférence
des états du monde probable sachant les
données qui ont été collectés donc ça
plus le premier parc en fait une autre
idée que j'ai eue c'est de donner des
noms à chacun des personnages pour y
voir plus clair donc le premier nous
allons faire a b c d e le plat comme la
france et plus
dcb a donc le problème que ces airs in
here in the great charles se charge de
l'accueil de données se talonnent ces
données négatives day sera en charge de
faire l'inférence sur l'état des mondes
probable à partir des données collectées
par irin
ayant même façon c'est direct vous faire
ça si on a une puissance de calcul
infini qui s'appelle la formule d ivoire
mon premier livre
si vous utilisez détails mais en
pratique on sait que c'est pas faisable
et qu'il va falloir trouver plein
d'approximations des approximations et
bien foutu et ce sera compliqué il ya il
aurait dans le champ de recherche sur
comment un ferrer les états du monde
probable à partir des données clés par
thierry irin plus d où on peut voir ça
comme la science ce que cherche à faire
la science en passant du général donc
c'est comprendre le monde mais
comprendre non ça suffit pas pour
calculer bonne récompense parce que là
on veut en plus une dimension éthique et
du couffo donné des récompenses
l'algorithme qui va faire de
l'utilisation que j'appelle à l'iss le
dernier une fois pas pour dieu et
d'ébène récompense pour calculer des
scores de désirabilité de l'état du
monde donc ça ça avec le job de
quelqu'un au personnage s'appelait
charlie donc c'est donc chercher charlie
son job c'est de calculer des trucs
qu'on vous qui serait bon pour
l'humanité que va dire ça comme ça
il est beaucoup plus de détails bien sûr
et enfin une dernière étape parce qu'on
plaisir bon ben voilà on a calculé le
score de désirabilité du monde ça suffit
suit de donner ça en fait il se trouve
que il ya un autre personnage qui va
être critique qui est qu'il appelle bob
qui est en charge de calcul des
incentives est ce que votre botte de fer
bob en particulier c'est modifier un peu
les récompenses calculé par charlie pour
y inclure des dessins des incitatifs à
ce qu'alice prennent soin globalement de
à ce que tous on circulera compense
fonctionne bien voir la meilleure s'il
fonctionne pas bien
ça c'est un feuille de route de façon
générale c'est cette décomposition des
compositions aurait rigolé des données
des qui infère les états du monde à
partir des données
charlie qui ajoute la dimension éthique
lorsqu on voudrait vouloir place comme
ça bob qui rajoute une dimension
d'incitatifs à l'iss et puis alice qui
fait la maximisation chez alice vous
allez retrouver des problèmes classiques
d'optimisation ceux qui font un peu de
maths connaissent chez erin et des et
vous allez retrouver la statistique
robuste des adversaires input donc les
koalas chf dont on a parlé un peu au
départ ce dont un peu ma thèse à traiter
aussi chez charles et vous allez trouver
des problèmes de philosophie morale de
ce qu'on voudrait en fait pour la
société et puis comment traduire sa
soudaine à lire algorithmique ce qui va
nous amener en fait vers la fin du livre
et voilà donc c'est dans chacun des
blocs de cette feuille de route
il ya des chantiers importants pour je
pense que il ya pas mal de sans trop de
prétention dans cette feuille de route
d'ici parlé il ya il ya quand même pas
mal de tests
voilà de quoi faire cesser pas tant le
livre ne prétend pas du tout
ne traitant pas du tout on arrête ne
résout aucune c'est l'intrusion
introduit donc cette feuille de route et
cette feuille de route est probablement
améliorable problème ailleurs de mieux
faire peut-être de conclure qu' on
aurait pu terminer avec trois blocs au
lieu de 2,5 alors que le mas attaque et
que peut-être qui a manié moyen moyen
d'être parcimonieux être finir avec
trois blocs au lieu de ça parce que j'ai
pas moi erin et ils peuvent être
fusionnés ou pas ou montré que au
contraire c'est très dangereux d'avoir
erin
qui fait la collecte de données
directement et qui donne directement adf
qui aura une boucle d'asservissement
entre entre chats entre entre bob qui
s'assure que je parlais en personnage je
pense que il ya peut-être moyen de
creuser un sujet de réflexion c'est
peut-être une boucle l'asservissement
entre bob et erin
il ya donc c'est une première
proposition il faut la voir comme une
sorte d'initialisation améliorable oui
c'est vraiment un peu de mieux d'aider
les gens à voir qu'est-ce qu'un sert
qu'à séka séka séka c'est le problème en
petites briques et surtout si jamais il
ya une brique qui paraît être un sujet
qui vous intéresse vous nous aidiez
intéressant lecteurs énormément
l'intérêt c'est un ami potentiellement
énormes en tête et ça serait bien de
travailler dessus que c'est vraiment des
objectifs sont objectivement ceux ci de
voir qu'est-ce qui est déficient ce
qu'aujourd'hui bonbons offerts sur ce
rallye sur quand même pas mal le
chercheur est sûre et beaucoup cherchent
sur des voeux il y en a il a rien sur
charmilles extrait voilà là où il ya des
manques soit c'est charlie bob charlie
bauer un peu days a je pense que assez
le plus le bloc le plus abouti le bloc
qui fait d'optimisation à la aujourd'hui
la communauté qui fait de l'autorisation
c'est l'une des plus solides
maintenant machine learning et puis même
si ce qu'ils ont aujourd'hui pas encore
suffisant ils bossent dessus voilà on
compte en regardant fait leur à leur
souci aujourd'hui ils sont vraiment à un
niveau de maturité ce qui fonde
optimisation ils sont là de plus
l'accélération hulot glog va accélérer
ce qui est déjà accéléré et c'est bien
j'aime bien sûr je simplifie bien
entendu encore des challenges de
l'optimisation mais c'est plus que les
autres les autres niveaux de ce circuit
sont beaucoup plus
une plus immature et sous étudié que je
dis pas que l'optimisation à aujourd'hui
et à problèmes aussi bien résolus que le
théorème de pythagore en géométrie
euclidienne jusque il est beaucoup plus
mature il est beaucoup plus pas voilà on
est déjà à un niveau assez satisfaisant
de la mathématisation de l'optimisation
d'une science de l'optimisation
par contre on est à un niveau très
insatisfaisant variantes de statistiques
robuste et fier donc comment comment
comment des vins faire correctement en
fait des données collectées par erin
c'est pas c'est pas résolu du tout où on
se rend compte que les données
collectées par erin sont très
multidimensionnelle et il faut qu' il
est très facile pour des de faire des
bêtises dans une référence dans son
interprétation de ces données la rn
lui-même
par exemple un des sujets de recherche
pas la boue c'est en fait dans la beauce
et l'empoisonnement donc les données
peuvent être en vente et 30 espace
peuvent être mévente être empoisonné
comment s'en prémunir à disposition ça
c'est que pour faire de machine learning
beaucoup de données et la meilleure
façon dans une façon de faire des deux
d'avoir beaucoup de données c'est un
d'avoir des données c'est d'aller
chercher soi-même mais on est limité par
semaine une autre façon acquis beaucoup
plus efficace pendant beaucoup de
données basse et collecter les données
qui sont sur internet et en particulier
du tube tu devrais tout ça juste prendre
les données qu'on leur donne donc les
utilisateurs mettent sur leur site et du
coup ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de
données mais du coup ça fait aussi des
données mises en ligne par des
utilisateurs potentiellement
malveillants maintenant je pense que il
une surface au moment de parler un peu
de charlie c'est la fin du livre
c'est que dans le rôle de charlie c'est
de savoir donc rappelle donc erin
collecter donner des vins faire l'état
du monde à partir de ces données pour
être un peu plus concret erin observe
les flamands roses et des faits une
théorie qui induit qui conclut que juste
que perrine à collecter les flamands 11
ne se trouve jamais au mali ne se trouve
là mais aller en norvège
c est toutefois que c'est en norvège je
pense qu'il ya pas de colorant rose en
arrière df qu'un conclut qu'il n'ya pas
de flamants roses en norvège et charlie
en fait donc la ccc des données
collectées charlie devra donner sorte de
morale une sorte de recommander son
d'orientation générale donc sur qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait ce qu'il
faudrait distribuer un peu plus de
flamands rouge en norvège
il faut faire muter muté faire l'amour
aux ogm et les mettre en norvège
est-ce que c'est souhaitable parce que
c'est désirable ou alors en fait quand
bien même c'est souhaitable en fait
comment quand bien ses souhaits thales
que c'est plus souhaitable que de que de
soutenir la population de signes qui vit
déjà en norvège et en fait ce qui nous
amène à un chapitre que juste pour être
plus concret soit un exemple gesticulant
dire oui
exemple concret un des gros problèmes
aujourd'hui sur youtube c'est la
modération des discours de haine
qu'est ce qui doit être modéré qu est-ce
qui doit être partagée qu'est ce qui
peut ne doit pas être prêt de partager
qu'est ce qui doit être censuré et ça
c'est une simulation très difficile et
ça ça des effets secondaires et tout ça
et du coup le d'un des grands défis
aujourd'hui de l'éthique des algorithmes
c'est de savoir comment est ce qu'on se
met d'accord sur ça
une façon de faire c'est de demander à
une personne ou un groupe de personne de
dire boire
là on va faire une ligne directe
directive probablement ce sapin en
proposant natif de ce que la plupart des
gens pensent et probablement sera plein
de failles en plus moi c'est vraiment
pas facile de débuter sa et du coup on a
des idées un peu livre c'est de faire en
sorte que cette modération soit le
résultat d'une un calcul fait par par
charlie et qui prend en compte
uniquement les préférences des
utilisateurs des humains de façon
générale donc c'est un petit peu ça le
genre de cas d'application en fait
imaginer plein de choses
est ce que ta vidéo est censuré parce
que c'est surtout est ce qu'elle doit
être recommandée ce qui limite les
points de suture vidéo qui a passé huit
ans au défenseur mais qui est zéro but
en huit ans par contre si la vidéo est
recommandé quelques oignons du pronostic
alors donc ce qui nous ramène avec la
question que vous les posez mais j'avais
j'avais un exemple qui était pas très
bien pour illustrer le challenge
oublions les biens portés gras dans
l'exemple de l'est
sur les vidéos donc arriver à evere
charlie donc arriver vers le bloc donc
qui doit qui doit donc on ratait donc la
collection des données inférences du
modèle du monde et la demande à partir
des données et un moment faut orienter
l'action d'optimisation orienter
l'action pour que le monde aille mieux
pour faire voir pour faire pour faire
très simple et même un peu ça peut avoir
l'air un peu prétentieux mais donc
cherchar lycée le bloc qui devrait
calculer si le monde va mieux avec cette
vidéo haineuse qui se propage et que les
gens comme entrant pour dénoncer et
éduquer garder cette attitude haineuse
c'est une attitude qui ne faut pas
reproduire etc
ou si le mans devra mieux si la vidéo
est au contraire pas propagé et filtrée
pour ne pas être vu c'est la triviale 1
il ya des cas il ya des cas où est des
cas où la censure on est bien l'effet
streisand
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que le
discours extrémiste par exemple peut
être dopé par la censure quelque chose
qui est interdite peuvent devenir un peu
devenir souhaitable et mais c'est pas
toujours souhaitable de promouvant de
propager de l'est s'est propagé à un
discours haineux parce qu'au contraire
un peu donné l'idée à d'autres et c est
ce qu on avance dans le livre et on ne
leur en ai pas de le remettre dans les
premiers ni les derniers à l'avancé on
s'est inspiré d'un paquet d'avants site
ainsi qu'un célèbre juriste du 9ème
siècle juriste altra hall il n'y a
qu'eux qui a donné le mot algorithmes
don mills est un juriste donc le celui
dans les deux ados à sa survie après
lequel les algorithmes sont nommés
étaient d'abord juriste avant d'être
algorithmes essien et algebris tu es en
fait c'est quelqu'un qui résolvait des
cas d'héritage et qui résolvait des
cadeaux c'est un juge et dans l'encré
dans le préambule de son bouquin
fondateur de l'algèbre il dit la chose
suivante est dit à chaque fois que je
regarde ce que vous devrez man legends
d'un jugement
je trouve que c'est toujours un nombre
ah mais attendez en fait le mot jugement
là on fait exprès de le traduire en
illyrie saab et saab dans la langue
arabe
ça veut dire calcul mais c'est aussi
utilisé pour dire je voie le jour du
jour de jugement s'appelle en arabe le
jour de grisaille anglaise et le jour de
calcul bon maintenant on est donc fort
podcast donc je peux faire la digression
et c'est marre de regarder la tradition
en fait fait la tradition islamique du
jour du jugement elle est très
algorithmique en pâtit en fait en
abondance dans cette religion il est il
est cru que
chaque personne à deux hanches côté
droit côté gauche et puis les anges fin
des comptes c'est donc ils regardent les
actions positives les actions négatives
et puis au jour du jugement on va
calculer en fait le jour du jugement
c'est le jour on va calculer le score à
droite et score à gauche le score des
bonnes actions et secours des mauvaises
actions juste juste pour l'expression
jouve du jugement et donc c'est un jour
fait rassurant calculs et à travailler
demi dans son bouquin il utilise le mot
hissab alors probablement pour dire
calcul mais en fait nous on a fait
exprès de traduire en jugement et en
explique dans le chapitre pourquoi parce
qu'en fait sans son bouquin qui a créé
l'algèbre s'était d'abord et avant tout
un bouquin qui permettait à des juges
qui ne connaissaient pas les maths de
résoudre des cas d'héritage sans être
mathématicien
alors qu'est ce qu'il leur a offert dans
ce bouquin il aura à faire des
algorithmes des recettes
il leur offre des recettes moi quand je
suis face à un tel cas d'héritage
je prends ceci je le divise par 2 je
prends cela je vous divise par trois je
retranche le reste la première opération
et c'est un nom qui donne une recette
une succession d'opérations une
succession d'actions à faire le calcul
et cette succession de calcul aboutit à
un membre
qu'est ce qu'il veut les gens quand ils
vont chez le juge pour résoudre un
querelles d'héritage
ils veulent que le juge se base sur la
loi coranique dans ce cas là pour dire
un tel raz 5 dirhams alors que l'autre
n'aura que trois de ses membres
et qu'est ce qui a mené à ce nombre un
algorithme donc le bouquin c'est un
bouquin d'algorithmes mais la motivation
est purement juridique ce jugement il
fallait faire des jugements
il fallait faire des jugements qui ne
fasse pas trop débat qui fasse qui met
les gens d'accord et ce qu'on soutient
en fait dans ce chapitre c'est que
aujourd'hui malgré les algorithmes et la
prise de décisions automatisé à très
grande échelle
en fait elle passe son temps à faire des
jugements et passe son temps à prendre
des jugements et a jugé que les devra
voir ça alors que moi je ne devrais pas
de voir que moi je devrais voir cette
vidéo alors que les vous devrait voir
cette autre vidéo que moi je devrais
être commandé ce film alors que l'indicé
anodin mais quand ça touche au choix
politiques au choix médicaux au choix
sportif au choix deux battus de
nourriture etc
c'est des jugements effectuées par des
algorithmes et qui influencent nos vies
et donc si on revient à cette situation
de crise mais en fait c'est plus pour
parler d'éthique l'éthique c'est la
philosophie morale c'est sur deux
branches de la philosophie où on
s'intéresse à ce qui devrait être un bon
jugement et en fait ce que j'entends
dans ce chapitre c'est que oui il faut
continuer à mener une réflexion
philosophique de ce qu'être devrait être
un rangement mais aussi il faut garder
en tête que aujourd'hui toutes versions
actuelles de la philosophie morale devra
pouvoir être donnée à des abouré devra
pouvoir être traduite en recettes
donc je sois suite ne se développer
certains trucs je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs deux éditeurs qui ont
peut-être un peu choqué à l'idée dire il
faut faire du calcul en éthique à
l'éthique on me dira c'est vraiment du
fond de nous la théorie du calcul issus
de l'aide juridique votre site et pour
répondre à des questions auprès des eti
qui n'était pas forcément le plus
délicat oui comme un commercial or à
dire des problèmes commercial des
querelles juridiques
raoni a réussi à résoudre tous les cas
d'héritage sans problème alors que les
autres juges il galérait ils tâtonnaient
il faisait les fractions alors quand on
regarde des solutions de la troisième
école toujours aux pressions il fallait
me fallait faire des algorithmes pour
que votre machine d'autres jugent moins
équipée est mathématiquement 4h30
aboutissent aux mêmes jugements
c'est j'en avais déjà parlé avec gilles
dowek précédent de probablement que l'on
compte un très bon mais à ses vingt six
ans un intéressant ce cas d'injustice
puisque c'est là qu'aujourd'hui des tic
et la plus formalisé sa perte à un
client important d'ailleurs ce qu'on
peut dire que moi je commence par
rappeler la grille de lecture est
beaucoup plus important en termes
éthiques que la justice aujourd'hui est
un débat pour une autre fois mais en
tout cas en justice on est obligé de le
formaliser d'en arriver à une conclusion
à la fin et c'est intéressant de se
demander d'où vient cette décision et
quel est le processus qui conduit à la
décision du juge est clairement là il ya
une partie qui est des textes de loi
mais c'est également intéressant de
réfléchir d'où viennent ces textes de
loi mais on peut se dire que les textes
de loi sont le résultat d'une réflexion
collective de débats de messages qui ont
été les sujets d'une personne à l'autre
violences étaient le résultat d'un
calcul sur ses calculs au sens
traitement de l'information calcul
social à quelqu'une sociale pour les
personnes qui en arrivent du coup un
texte de loi qui est le résultat d'un
calcul
ensuite le juge il prend son résultat du
calcul lui mais dans sa tête il regarde
des détails spécifiques de la sphère
qu'il a en face de lui donc ça peut être
des données ça peut être la tête d'une
personne avec le discours de d'un avocat
tout ça c'est des données il combine ça
avec le lait aux données qui sont des
textes de loi et avec un algorithme et
qu'il a dans sa tête
raisonnement qui fait pour en arriver à
une conclusion donc il y ajouter un
procédure tout un calcul ton traitement
d'informations qui conduit à au final à
ce qui est un jugement est l'un des
problèmes juge aura plusieurs problèmes
peuvent être en passant par sam est un
des problèmes est typiquement du juge
c'est que il ya cette partie à
l'intérieur du bus qui est pas
externaliser
et c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles c'est pas externaliser sais
que c'est difficile d'externaliser sa
externe et les cerveaux qui apparaît
beaucoup donc l'a84
s'il ya des mots qui apparaît dans la
quatrième de couverture du livre on est
dans une très heureux au fur et à mesure
que les technologies de l'information on
externalise à tout ça en tout cas on n'a
plus la capacité d'externaliser le
traitement de l'information
donc on peut se dire assez horrible de
dextérité de traitement d'information
qui a lieu d'arrêter d'un jugement fait
ça pas mal d'avantagés notamment le
problème des biais de fait que le
traitement d'informations par deux juges
sera différent parce qu'ils utilisent le
cerveau différent et ça ça conduit a
notamment pas mal de billets qui ont été
pas mal étudié attentivement aux états
unis des bières assiste chez chez chez
les juges et c'est très difficile d'être
robuste en tant que juge assez bien
racistes si c'est inconscient c'est
certainement pas facile du coup il ya
vraiment un intérêt à chercher à
externaliser ce qui se passe dans la
tête d'un juge pour avoir des jugements
plus plus régulier sans billet et c'est
l'un des très grands défis que cet angle
de recherche et du coup on fait savoir
cette vision algorithmique c'est pas
quelque chose qui détruit c'est quelque
chose qui clarifie la manière dont les
prises de décisions sont faites en
pratique nos sociétés ça aussi pas mal
d'intérêt parce que plusieurs niveaux un
désintérêt qui est discutée attendons
chapitre cc autre xavi de préférer le
titre initial de livres avant que les
mambas n'ont jamais de qui un des trucs
dont on parle c'est que la canicule et
les juges ce traitement où on peut se
demander
voilà on a tendance à voir cette
intuition qui a été quelque chose en
plus des données pas en panne en pleine
action de conscience on a tendance à
penser que la conscience c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut pas observer qu on peut
même pas un ferrer des données et si
vous défendez ça n'est pas du tout vous
avez tant c'est tout à fait possible de
penser ça mais le problème avec ça c'est
que ça se prête pas bien un jugement
algorithmique et en pratique si on
réfléchit un juge qui juge quelqu'un
devant lui il va pas aller observer un
trekkie pas observable de toute façon
donc le traitement d'informations du
juge ne peut pas utiliser cette notion
de conscience phénoménal qui serait
comme impossible incalculables et du
coup cette contrainte de quelques habité
finalement elle est intéressante parce
qu'elle permet aussi de court circuiter
des débats qui sont en fait pas
pertinent à la prise de décisions
algorithmique traitement de
l'information telle qu'est capable de
faire juge
c'est un des aspects fait facilement de
ça et parce que pas mal d'aspects assez
fascinant du conseil avoir cet angle de
vue un des trucs que dont ont parlé avec
gilles dowek donc je dois parler avec
moi c'est le point de la calculabilité
d'un algorithme c'est que par exemple on
peut imaginer des algorithmes que suivra
le juge
mais si si si l'algorithme du juge c'est
prouver que la personne est coupable
hier à partir d'actium formaliser et qui
sont assez puissants qu'ils contiennent
arithmétique bas ont pu démontrer que on
pourra pas démontré que le juge finira
par avoir une décision c'est que
justement il pourra calculer calculé
calcul est calculé et en fait ce calcul
ne finirait jamais et ça c'est un énorme
problème parce que finalement on a des
contraintes algorithmes pratiques sur le
fait par exemple en seront encore une
vidéo youtube n'a pas envie que la
gouaille de youtube 10 à 30 ans je
calcule ce qui est désirable pour toi
qui passe un calcul infinie en fait on a
même des contraintes de en terme de
complexité des calculs ces gens quand
ils sont sur youtube
ils veulent des réponses rapidement
cherché macron sur youtube il ya un vrai
dit la billettique sur quelle vidéo va
être recommandée en premier ont
désormais tout ça et ça peut être très
compliqué mais l'algorithme l'étude doit
répondre en temps très très très rapide
parce que sinon utilisateurs avaient
quitté youtube et du coup on a des
contraintes de temps de calcul sur la
décision l'appréciation du logement il
sape pour la location de vidéos c'est
toutes sortes de contraintes qui sont en
fait ultra pertinente
lorsqu'on considère dès aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on peut parler avec diana une
thèse qu'on défend particulier dans ce
chapitre
sa philosophie dépanordi à voir avec la
philosophie deadline enfin la thèse
qu'il a défendue c'est le fait que aucun
oui là la mort ne peut tenir la
complicité de la morale c'est donc ce
seront ceux qu'on postule qui en fait
c'est chamakh c'est parce que je suis
parce que c'est un peu par nécessité que
vu que comparé d'algorithmes morale doit
être conclue la bhl et j'allais écrire
un premier draft de ce truc
je suis content quand même
et puis on se dit mais c'est à dire
qu'on peut utiliser la bioéthique
joséphine et c'est là que j'ai commencé
à dire maintenant qu'elles sont une
notion importante et algorithmique
jacques l'habiter la calculabilité a
déjà parlé la théorie de la complexité
on t'encule la part des la complexité en
ligne nombre des lignes de codes
complexité de ce lot 9
on va en parler et puis on peut rajouter
la résilience aux fautes pas toutes les
notions de l'algorithmique sont
naturellement des problèmes pour la
philosophie morale et donc en
particulier celles que détestent qu'on
défend c'est par rapport à la complexité
de ce nom c'est à dire du nombre de
lignes de code d'un code moral
finalement la quantité de solvalla c'est
le nombre pensaient genre à penser un
voulais écrire un sms illimités en
caractères si vous pouvez le dire la
même chose avec moins de caractère vous
êtes content mais il ya des choses que
vous ne pouvez pas dire au dessous d'un
certain nombre de caractères alors le
nom de calcaire minimale qu'il vous faut
pour dire cette chose c'est la
complexité solomonoff de cette chose non
un gars comme celle-ci notion qui qui
est alors là il a dit comme ça qu'ils
restent encore ça dépend de la machine
des petits détails comme ça mais en fait
elle est essentiellement bien définis à
tort et c'est vraiment des notions les
plus fondamentales de la science de
l'information et ces merveilleuses
certains objets mais ce site plus de
créatures que d'autres c'est ça et donc
la morale quand on entend ici c'est que
la philosophie morale satisfaisante ne
pourra pas tenir en moins de 500 des
choses comme ça et tu me diras l'audio
je pense que même sans s'en cacher sur
l'argent parce que c'est juste une borne
inférieure à ce à quoi il faudra de 500
pages mais ces sas a des conséquences
importantes
en fait c'est l'argument de turing qui
en 1950 concours aux cycles quelques
animaux ne pourra pas l'écrire c'est
vraiment juste pour ce coin que c'est
vraiment compliqué à la morale
par exemple on peut se dire que la
cultive mans pour la morale c'est assez
pertinent de pouvoir savoir ce qu'est un
chat un chat
parce qu'on préfère présente que les
chasses survie donc heureux et du coup
il semble pertinent à la philosophie
morale de savoir d'avoir moins un
algorithme de détection d'un chat le
problème c'est que détecter un chat
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas faire
à moins d'avoir un code qui fait des
centaines des milliers peut-être de
paramètres dans un réseau de neurones
donc ça correspond en gros à un méga
octets et il a pris le chat mais bien
sûr il ya plein d'autres choses entrent
au cd qui sont importants et rien que
d'écrire ces objets dans la société
requiert déjà des codes absolument
énorme
donc c'est un peu des arguments
importants pour dire que voit pas écrire
le code et permettant des gars c'est
déjà beaucoup
et du coup comme comme de la même
manière que tu n'y as dit pour faire un
algorithme puissant va falloir vous
croient pas l'écrire du coup va falloir
faire du machinisme pour pour écrire la
barre pour les calonnois il va falloir
faire pareil il va falloir s'appuyer sur
et au monde des composants qui font de
la condition d'ailleurs l'avoir écrite
quand on veut quand on veut décider dans
le domaine médical si on doit adopter
telle procédure ou pas dans
l'accouchement on va pas lire un livre
de morale on va inviter un panel des
tice east qui vont débattre et qu'ils
vont juger si c'est moral ou immoral de
faire cette procédure pendant
l'accouchement
mais ce panel des tigistes ne seraient
pas capables de nous écrire un livre de
recettes qui nous dit ce qu'il fallait
faire pour ne pas les réinviter la
prochaine fois en fait c'est ce que
l'ennemi c'est ce qu'il avait fait pour
l'algèbre il avait jugé que résoudre des
équations c'est un truc très bête qui
peut tenir en un livre alors écrivant le
donc j'écris un livre de recettes comme
ça les autres juges n'ont plus besoin de
m'inviter à leur jugement quand il quand
il s'en coller face à un cas d'héritage
difficile voilà ça tient on à petit
livre on va appeler ça l'algèbre à
résoudre des équations pour des
questions éthiques
on a pas on n'a pas un livre n'a pas un
livre comme ça on n'a pas pour des sous
question oui on peut peut-être qu'on
peut arriver à un consensus social sur
je ne sais pas moi l'avortement au delà
de quatre mois où l'avortement ou
huitième mois on a peut-être un
consensus social assez fort que au delà
de huit mois les risques le traumatisme
gigantesque sur la maman et c est que en
a conclu que ça ne se fait pas et donc
plus besoin d'inviter un panel des
cistes mais souvent dans les questions
éthiques
on n'a pas de source qu'est ce qu'on
fait on invite un panel de réseaux de
neurones l'adessa des humains qui ont
appris qu'ils ont appris par leur
expérience dans leur sagesse par leur
nombre d'accouchements qu'ils ont vu par
le nombre de problèmes qu'ils ont vu et
c'est par leur lecture par le nombre de
livres qui nous ont lu à émettre un
jugement moral et au fait ça c'est pour
pour se convaincre de la thèse du
chapitre 16 il suffit juste de penser à
ça un panel des 10,6 tu n'es jamais
capables de nous écrire un livre
définitif en éthique beaucoup aussi
et sait pas écrire cette façon vraiment
parents eux il en a pris même si on
réfléchit pardon point un texte de loi
en fait c'est pas algorithmique même des
gens on défend le fait que c'est
important que ce soit pas algorithmique
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à capturer
toute la complexité de la morale dans un
livre de bord un texte de loi
c'est important de laisser partir cette
complexité on peut pas mettre dans le
livre du qu'on le laisse dans le cerveau
l'éthicien d'été 6,2 du juge dans
l'autre il ya un autre un mot important
dans cette thèse c'est le mot
satisfaisant c'est assez compliqué pas
mal de choses à dire sur satisfaisant
oui mais un des aspects que je trouve
assez intéressant c'est de se dire c'est
que parce qu'on a tendance à vouloir
alors on peut s'exprimer sur des
problèmes moraux qu'on arrive bien
concevoir
sauf qu'il faut imaginer que
l'intelligence art afin que l'algorithme
youtube est constamment il ils voient
des choses des vidéos qu'on n'arrive
même pas à imaginer que l on n'a jamais
imaginé
du coup plus globalement les décisions
de cet algorithme doivent dépendre de
choses que les nous autres on n'est pas
capable d'imaginer mais il doit quand
même donner offrir du vin choisir de
modérer ou non des vidéos qui nous est
difficile d'imaginer et du coup il ya
une phase d' extrapolations qui est
absolument indispensable et le nombre de
cas imaginables qui en plus voilà la
décision qu'on va faire parlante pour
une vidéo que dépendent aussi de tout le
contexte de youtube peut-être que telle
vidéo
bon en fait en temps normal se passe
mais là dans le contexte actuel où il ya
tellement social qui est née sa passion
ça passe pas pour pouvoir prendre sa
décision il faut comprendre tout le
contexte social et tout ça et le nombre
de contextes sociaux imaginables pas
exponentielle trucs et donc et du coup
là l'amour
il était important pour qu'elle la
morale sur le soit y soient
satisfaisantes
il faut qu'elle soit néanmoins capable
d'offrir des jugements d'elie saab
même dans ces cas qui est ou qui n'ont
jamais été imaginé par les développeurs
de la normale et ça ça rend le problème
très difficile way est un autre aspect
important de ce chapitre c'est parce que
nous pensons que ce chapitre parle pas
mal de tout ça et petit à petit nous qui
violent sur le problème de ceux
qu'utilisaient la philosophie online qui
est le fait que sa part est un chantier
énorme et tout ça on corrézien il faut
absolument qu'on fasse qu'on fasse un
peu pour objectif vous dire à papa et
moi d'y aller pas à pas comme ça c'est
que ça va prendre plus de temps et du
coup une autre problème c'est que
pendant qu'on réfléchisse à la
philosophie morale
l'algorithme youtube continue à
recommander vidéo qui recourent et du
coup on est un peu chaque année qui
passe où on ne gère pas le problème de
lentilles vaccination jeanne brugère pas
le problème du climato sceptisme
scepticisme on ne gère pas le problème
de la santé mentale
ce sont des années où des centaines de
millions des premiers santé mentale qui
continuent à avoir des vidéos déprimante
on est tous à chaque année qui passe à
ne pas avoir de solution c'est une année
où il ya beaucoup de dommages il ya
vraiment une urgence et il faut vraiment
réussir à concevoir cet algorithme et du
coup le sait le calcul non pas moral
mais c'est du coup le calcul de la
morale qui doit être fait également en
un temps raisonnable dans un discussions
récentes avec une discussion des as en
appliquant des chercheurs de très haut
niveau machine learning quelqu'un avait
dit oui mais le problème d'alignement
même dans le contexte des réseaux
soupçonne le problème d'alignement c'est
pas très urgent et des urgences plus
importante quand le changement
climatique ou la société n'est pas
convaincu de l'urgence de ce truc de ce
problème
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux aggrave
le fait que la société n'est pas
consciente de l'urgence du changement
climatique problèmes
le grave est l'urgence de résoudre
l'alignement des réseaux sociaux
elle surpasse l'urgence climatique
duquel l'ue qu'elle inclut aujourd'hui
le plus grand faiseur d'opinion ces
réseaux sociaux et donc si on résout
l'alignement des réseaux sociaux ça va
nous aider à résoudre le fait que la
société devienne plus conscientes de
l'urgence climatique si on focalise sur
l'urgence climatique
en disant non l'alignement des réseaux
sociaux c'est secondaire profite en fait
on va faire du mal à la cause de
changement à la cause quand et dans
quelle nation priorities la cause de
l'urgence climatique et que en faisant
ça on décrète que aligner les réseaux
sociaux c'est pas aussi aux gens on ne
travaille pas dessus en fait en faisant
cette décision on va nuire à la cause
qu'on croyait être la plus urgente n'est
là je pense que c'est mon livre mais en
gros pour quasiment toutes les causes la
priorité c'est de l'information parce
que les gens sont mal informés sont pas
assez sensibilisés et du coup à peu près
n'importe quelle cause le goulot
d'étranglement le truc qui va permettre
à cause peut-être beaucoup mieux
adresser le traitement de l'information
qui font le plaignant quelques
exactement le contrôle du flux de
l'information à l'échelle à l'échelle
mondiale et du coup le ne sait vraiment
les accords et de recommandations donc
ça c'est un argument je pense qu'ils
vraiment très très ça trop peu mis en
avant et qu'il faut vraiment avoir fait
un faux pas beaucoup de gens parlent de
prendre l'éducation ça que les sites ont
été mieux éduqués ça serait super à tout
ça
vous la question mais comment est ce
qu'on fait pour mieux éduquer les gens
et les gens vont tout de suite pensé à
l'éducation nationale bonjour mais le
truc qui fait vraiment une différence
majeure par quoi l'information passe
même si on va améliorer l'éducation on
va falloir améliorer les enseignants
comment toucher les enseignants bas au
final lui recommander l'information
auxquelles ces gens sont exposés de
manière quotidienne
c'est là qu'on a eu le plus gros levier
d'action c'est un peu frustrant qu'elle
pas plus de gens voient voit se lever
d'action absolument critique pour pour
toutes sortes de causes
donc c'est assez important peut-être
finir juste par rapport à éducation
versus opinion publique il ya des propos
très intéressant sur lequel je suis
tombé à savon de bourdieu pierre
bourdieu c'est un des plus grands
sociologues ou moins français du 20e
siècle et où il parle de l'éducation et
la télévision c'est c'est cesser manque
autant il n'a pas eu beaucoup de
difficultés à faire passer un message
pareil autant aujourd'hui on se rend pas
compte que les réseaux sociaux c'est
plus fort que la télé que les propos de
boer 200 valable il faut juste remplacé
télé paraissent aujourd'hui je passe sur
les machines d'habitude quand ne pas
donner les chiffres de youtube oui et en
fait là les gens perdent donc les
chiffres youtube
les gens ne se rendent pas compte juste
de leur ampleur c'est en une minute
c'est plus de 4 millions 6 ou presque
4,5 millions de vues par minute alors
qu'il ya à peine 4 millions 3 recherche
google par minute
c'est plus en une minute mème chose de
vues sur youtube que de recherche
requête sur google selon des chiffres
selon cette fois selon le chief product
officer donc le directeur produit de
youtube 70% dans 70% des vues sur
youtube sans des vues recommander par le
green n ont pas de vue activement
cherché par l'autre parent par
l'audience pour une vidéo où j'ai
cherché activement ces instants hall
probablement je vais prendre trois
autres qui m'ont été recommandé que je
vais voir parce qu'une longue au rythme
on a décidé ainsi et ça fait ça c'est
que 5 millions ça ce phénomène est en
train de se produire cinq millions de
fois par minute
partout dans le monde c'est plus que
cinq fois plus que l'audience de
facebook est je crois une quinzaine de
fois plus que l'instinct gras ça dépasse
de loin les autres acteurs majeurs
auxquels on pense twitter twitter c'est
négligeable et que et bien sûr à telle
est ma télé c'est juste ultra
négligeable par rapport à tout ça est en
fait il suffit de regarder ce que disait
bourdieu pour la télé de l'appliquer
aujourd'hui aux réseaux sociaux et à la
question de l'éducation pour se rendre
compte qu'il est très urgent il est
moralement urgent de utilisé de manière
bénéfique pour la société et ses canons
la météo aux gens qui disent que
l'éducation c'est m
et le truc c'est que sur youtube il ya
10 compte tenu de très grande qualité
comme éducation et de façon assez pour
coup avec un peu énervé et je parle pas
tellement pour ma chaîne sport
mais les vues des chaînes youtube
scientifiques sont en train de laisser
que alors que youtube était censée
combattre les maux conspirationnistes
alors combat et émouvant conspiration et
définit ses travers mais si c'est pour
remplacer par d'autres contenus ce cas
pas besoin que ce soit défectueuse pour
que ça soit problématique juste et des
vidéos qui attire l'attention sur des
faux problèmes
enfin ces deux êtres tension platement
gaspillé l'exemple
et qui en plus habitue les gens à
s'intéresser à défaut le problème à
l'envers ce show que malheureusement les
vidéos sont vraiment d'un contenu
éducatif de très grande qualité
ben ouais leur nombre de vues stagne
diminue et sont pas du tout promu à
l'échelle que pour si quelqu'un
quelqu'un qui pète pas habitués à cet
argumentaire dit mais pourquoi ils
focalisent tellement sur youtube en
valais les chiffres d'audience convient
de donner en fait le propos kantien il
et il est valable pour toute plateforme
faisait d'opinion influents se d'opinion
si dans trois ans pour une raison ou une
autre ce n'est plus le tube mais c'est
abcd là le propos est valable pour abcd
jusqu'aujourd'hui en l'état actuel des
choses
aujourd'hui à l'euro en parle la
plateforme qui domine qui domine
l'opinion publique qui domine
l'exposition médiatique de foot flûte
matité c'est youtube
c'est donc à deux milliards par un
milliard d'heures de vues par jour donc
une sur deux milliards d'utilisateurs un
peu plus demi heure environ
ça fait trente minutes par jour et c'est
sans se rendre compte que l'exposition
ce qui convainc c'est la répétition peut
et du coup c'est une exposition répétée
tous les jours tous les jours tous les
jours du coup plus jours et en plus il
ya des phénomènes de youtube qui va être
optimiste où se mettre la tension est
pour m optimiser la tension des contenus
plus addictif que d'autres et surtout il
ya des façons d'être d'y aller compte
remettre directement la vidéo horrible
mais petit à petit une citation
notamment de jeu ce qui concerne l'asie
n'est pas tout fait que ce qui touche
chic sexy qui dit que j'avais un site
annoncé
c'est comme si vous n'y étais jamais
suffisamment radicaux pour youtube mais
tu dois mettre un peu plus un peu plus
et c'est un truc qui sait qu'il ya sans
doute eu lieu sur énormément de
personnes qui se polarise de plus en
plus
pas énormément parler de polarisation
mais la polarisation par exemple aux
états unis dans toutes sortes de pays
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
préoccupe la fraude échelle il ya des
preuves de perception d'un camp à
l'autre tous les phénomènes de
mécanismes psychologiques qui sont bien
connues des psychologues et qui sont
justes mises à l'échelle de ses
algorithmes
du coup il y avait sans doute une
urgence à faire quelque chose par
rapport à tout ça enfin il ya un
chapitre 17
le chapitre 17 s'appelle vous pouvez
aider
l'invitation à participer à ce fabuleux
chantier je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
moyens de participer aux français par la
chose je pense que gérant de s'informer
parce que c'est une chose contre
intuitif
je pense avoir des fruits pour sfr
beaucoup dans le livre c'est d'inviter
les gens à vraiment réfléchir peut il ya
beaucoup d'autres questionnements
surtout va pas prendre ce qu'on dit
points acquis voire gagner tellement de
choses qu'on dit qu'ils sont des
matériaux largement et en fait il faut
il faut débattre et on est très loin
d'être sûrs de nous du coup il y avoir
une invitation à ça mais faut aussi
faire gaffe à bien communiquer sur ses
idées parce que il ya pas mal d'idées
qu'on présente qui sont faciles à
caricaturer à déformer à moquer et si on
les défend mal c'est facile de ceux de
présenter de manière contreproductive
donc voilà même dans la manière de
communiquer surtout ça vous invite à
être robustement bénéfique dans la
manière de parler tout ça
oui il ya des questions assez à 1 contre
intuitive sur le fait de comment on
parlait en fait c'est un sujet assez
difficile
c'est c'est très tentant de moquer
certains propos contient dans ce livre
donc j'ai personnellement j'aurais
moquer certains propos tenus dans ce
livre il n'ya même pas de trois ans donc
c'est c'est donc c'est un sujet en fait
fait pourquoi être très très haut ni
très créés dans les généralités
aujourd'hui il est important pour
l'humanité de mener une discussion sur
ce que ce qu'est que ce qui est pensé à
prendre réfléchir 5e en essayant de
réfléchir à ce que c'est que
l'intelligence artificielle on s'est
rendu compte qu'il qu'on ne sait pas
dans l'histoire d'humanité suffisamment
poser la question de caisse que
réfléchir qu'est-ce que l'analyse
centenaire l'informatique n'est pas né
du désir de turing de multiplier les
gadgets ou de rendre des gadgets
existants plus performant c'est séné du
questionnement très philosophique qu'est
ce qu'on peut savoir qu'est ce qu'on
peut savoir alors en dessous savoir que
ce qui est calculable entend fini et
c'est abbas attendent bien il ya cette
procédure qui est universel et qui peut
calculer tout ce qui peut être ce qui
peut l'être et ça donnait le la machine
universelle est tellement universel
qu'aujourd'hui comme disait michel
serres vous entrez dans une shop on ne
peut pas deviner le métier d'une
personne à partir de ces outils à jour
de notre avis n'est que intel et c'est
vraiment comptable parce qu'il est
habillé tellement dresscode de comptable
alors qu'un autre il est cependant
mécaniciens ingénieurs en mécanique
parce qu'il revient du chant titre il
revient du chantier ou du jean etc
mais aujourd'hui ils seront tous assis
face à un ordinateur l'ingénieur
mécanique en train de bidouiller hun sen
logiciel de dessin mécanique sur moi
katia ou solidworks ou d'autres seraient
en train de faire sa comptabilité sur un
tableau ils ont tous la même machine
universel le même outil
et cet outil est universel parce que la
réflexion initiale de turing
pour ted sur qu'est ce qui est peut être
calculé qu est ce qui peut être fait de
manière universelle et maintenant on
arrive à un autre stade où on se pose la
question comment programmer cet outil
qui veut peut calculer les choses et on
s'est rendu compte qu'il faut apprendre
par les bonnets et là on va rebelote
reposer une question sur nous mêmes
comment on faisait donc déjà en fête en
se posant la question de l'intelligence
artificielle
il est très intense important de noter
que le questionnement scientifique
autour de l'intelligence artificielle
que se faire sans même avant qu'elle en
a 500 évoqué la notion d'ordinateur
qu'est-ce que regarder des données et
inférées une loi ça c'est bien traité
dans son premier livre
aujourd'hui on est face à ce type de
questionnement donc c'est pas c'est pas
une histoire des informaticiens ou de
geek ou de programmeurs seulement et et
certains propos quand on n'est pas
habitué
quand on n'est pas habitués peuvent
sembler prétentieux de la part de
l'information
que viennent faire deux informaticiens
dans un questionnement éthique que vient
de faire que vient faire l'informatique
sur des questionnements sur les biais
cognitifs du cerveau en fait le cerveau
c'est une machine c'est aujourd'hui le
meilleur exemple qu'on a au moins vivent
d'une machine qui regardent des données
qui à faire des lois et qui prend des
décisions pour reprendre une analogie
qui a été usée et abusée par un parent
par les gens machine learning l'aviation
les premiers à comprendre comment vole
un oiseau s'était pas les ornithologues
c'est ce qu'ils ont fabriqué un avion
ratisser un oiseau artificielle qui sont
des contrats où il ya une histoire de
portance et de mécanique des fluides et
d'air qui coule soul elle c'est pareil
aujourd'hui on est en train de mener
face à un besoin de réfléchir à ce que
c'est que réfléchir
d'après réfléchir à ce que c'est que
réfléchir à prendre déduire conclure et
et des fois en peu de facilité d'accord
avec moi sur ce point mais il ya une 1re
ligue à nice mais humain chez nous
qu'ils rejettent certains propos parce
que on n'accepte pas d'être on n'accepte
pas que notre nature humaine fasse
l'objet d'une réflexion qui al'air
simplificatrice non moi je suis plus que
tout ça ne suis pas une machine
je suis pas un automatisme non non non
moi je suis au delà des noms je ne peux
pas être je ne peux pas être ce que je
ne peux pas être ce que dit tel
chercheur sur les biais cognitif ou tel
chercheur sur les aider les erreurs de
jugement du cerveau si la manger ou pas
tu peux dire à mes parents vous avez
jugé sur mon frère plus favorablement en
plus des favoris que moi parce que vous
aviez manger avant ils vont par yvan de
dire ils vont pas accepter alors que la
science ok mais j'ai fait des travaux
empiriques montrent que les juges par
exemple le sens plus clément après avoir
mangé que bas en tout cas moi pour mon
jury thèse on m'a conseillé d'offrir des
cookies ils ont pas toucher aux cookies
en l'air d'être bien alerté les gens ils
ont touché au quiz après la délibération
des histoires comme les biais cognitif
quand on en entend parler on est
banalisée à dire non non moi je suis pas
ça je suis pas un truc prédictible par
des statistiques et c'est pareil pour
beaucoup de propos pas que du livre mais
de propos aujourd'hui
tenu par les gens qui mène la réflexion
sur l'intelligence artificielle
ce n'est pas une réflexion sur un gadget
c'est une réflexion sur un acte
fondamental sur terre qui est
l'intelligence qui pour l'instant existe
de manière intéressante chez les humains
mais qui pourrait exister sous d'autres
formes
tout comme l'acte de planer dans les
airs existe maintenant dans une forme
des mécaniques métalliques et en
ferraille
il n'est pas exclu si on automatise bien
ces procédés d'aller au delà
ouhlala ouais je pense qu'on a c'est un
des aspects du livre qu'on a préféré
garder ne pas donner autant d'importance
c'est que la limite l'intelligence
humaine comme limite il faut pas être
tentés de ce corps auront lieu il ya
souvent un appel à la respectabilité à
la sobriété oui c'est important c'est
important d'être sobre et humble quand
on parle de choses complexes mais il
faut pas faire ce que je fais de la
règle de l'antiquaille par prétexte de
sobriété d'un des deux habitude de
modestie dénigrer toute personne ou tout
propos qui nous paraît spectaculaire
quelqu'un qui nous dit il n'est pas
impossible ou quelqu'un qui nous dit je
j'estime que il y aura une intelligence
de niveau humain dans les trois
décennies qui viennent
faut faire attention à la tentation de
le moquer tout de suite parce que son
propos paraît fantaisiste
surtout s'ils allaient me suis dit ça
comme ça mais si mu et des probabilités
qui montrent qu'il est incertain
ça va faire plus près fichiers alors que
messi ça c'est clairement un des points
délicats c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
discussion sur l'intelligence
artificielle est monopolisé par pas mal
de gens qui sont très très très sûrs
d'eux et qui dans les deux sens le déni
ou l'affirmation c'est ça et qui voit
qui parle du futur comme ce soit qui
font des prédictions détermination de
futuribles swell qui interdisent les
gens de parler du futur exact c'est
extrêmement prometic pour la raison de
parler en début de podcasts ce qui est
que si on ne se prépare pas pour
l'avenir on va dans la réaction et pas
de l'anticipation et il y aura des
effets secondaires qui arriveront sera
pas prêt et plus les algorithmes sont
influents plus l'ampleur de ces effets
secondaires risquent d'être énormes et
d'être très problématique est du coup
plus on s'expose plus enfin si on si on
n'encourage pas plus les gens à essayer
de se projeter non pas vers vers un
avenir plus vert plusieurs à venir
plausible et en particulier ceux où vous
savez le plus mal parce que c'est sûr
cela qui va falloir se préparer
davantage
bah en fait son exposé l'humanité a de
gros danger je vais revenir dessus c'est
une chose que je pense que j'étais pas
suivi en clair je pense que c'est
important de revenir dessus sur
l'histoire du déni et de la prédiction
certaines surtout face à une audience
française l'impression que donc les dans
la société française ceux qui ont fait
des maths la culture boma qui liste etc
qui valorise la rigueur etc
mais y'a papa que pas que dans les
cursus mathématiques mais même en cursus
en sciences sociales et une tendance à
valoriser le propos qui relativise si
quelqu'un vous dit l'intelligence
artificielle a changé l'humanité ok
pourquoi pas mais si vous aussi vous
pouvez faire carrière sur le fait de
faire du déni de ce type de propos
l'intelligence artificielle ne va pas
changer l'avenir n'existe pas pour citer
un livre le le changement qu'on nous
promet ne viendra jamais parce que
regarder les avions volant les attend
toujours
et peut-être ça s'est passé n'est pas
propre à la france d impression parce
que si on compare avec les médias
suisses je sais pas c'est une impression
d'un projet et probablement fou erronée
de ma part et méfiez vous de la
respectabilité dû au fait de dénigrer ou
de nier qu'il y à il ya des gens qui
promettent le grand soir demain à 13h30
oui c'est problématique les gens qui me
disent l'intelligence artificielle
dépassera l'humain dedans dans cinq ans
avec certitude où un demi-point à 1%
juste pour dire que c'est on estime
qu'elle est assez faible mais elle est
non il n'est pas non nulle et lé pa
mules et dans que tout comme tout quand
il faut se méfier de ceux qui affirme
avec certitude que ça va arriver et que
l'intelligence finale dépassera dumas ça
ça je pense que grosso modo la société
le journaliste s'en méfient suffisamment
ceux dont les chaussures la liste
la société ne se méfie pas suffisamment
c'est l'autre côté le déni le déni avec
certitude donc autant on va se méfier de
quelqu'un qui vous dit l'intérieur si
elle arrivera dans cinq ans et on va pas
le faire passer à la télé par contre
quelqu'un qui dit l'intelligence
artificielle c'est de la hype et du buzz
pour rien j'ai l'impression que cette
personne aura accès aux médias la
société même
mais même chez nos collègues c'est cette
tendance à être respectable on en parle
parle du brier respectabilité
prétendants livre d'un chapitre 17
les appels à la bienveillance dans la
chaîne aussi t'es pas tenues etc
c'est pas juste une histoire de
bisounours c'est fondamental quand on
veut discuter de quelque chose ou on a
beaucoup de on a beaucoup de pulsions
des gones
on n'accepte pas que nous autres humains
nous seront dépassés par les machines on
n'accepte pas que des histoires à toute
bête de biais cognitifs peuvent
expliquer un choix amoureux ou je sais
pas moi le familiaux religieux en
attendant on a tendance à aix très
égoïste pour dire dans les choix des
choix religieux familiaux amoureux ne
peuvent pas être aussi bête est aussi
mécanique que ce qui est en train de me
raconter ce monsieur sur les blés
cognitif d'appareils et je ne faut pas
se laisser il faut pas se laisser
prendre par le détail à l'isthme annoncé
je pense que le disait da pour le coup
c'est avec des bâtons mieux pas vraiment
là on a fait un énorme effort qui
beaucoup dans tout le livre quoi pour
essayer d'être aussi bienveillant union
c'est aussi six aussi modeste aussi que
possible quoi vraiment et je pense que
sur ce sujet surtout sur l'intelligence
artificielle où il ya beaucoup il ya
beaucoup de hype il ya beaucoup de gens
qui raconte des trucs improbables
il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
critiquer violemment tout ça et il ya un
peu de la caricature des deux côtés et
faut vraiment éviter de tomber dans ce
piège
il ya vraiment un truc qui se passe avec
le traitement de l'information
aujourd'hui qui est vraiment pas comme
avant qu'ils aient vraiment aidé ampleur
démesurée est vraiment un truc subtil
qui se passe il ya vraiment des
préoccupations d'avoir et c'est super
important de bien réfléchir de bien te
tiens bien débattre à ce sujet d'éviter
surtout la moquerie sarcasmes parce que
ces soins très subtil
c'est si tentante de moquer un truc qui
nous paraît tort
toujours dans la prédiction est ce qu'il
ya des passerelles humains il ya un
exemple qui était sorti par nikos
troupes dans son livre qui était repris
par un saut en hauteur au sol de léo
zila c'était avant que début du siècle
du 20e siècle les années 30
facile début que ça le la sommité en
physique atomique c'était auteurs forte
donc le bien sûr einstein la relativité
etc et en physique atomique donc les
collisions de protons et c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait un peu de physique je rappelle
l'expérience de rutherford
donc c'était monsieur monsieur physique
atomique et dans un discours à la royal
society société royale la sorte
d'académie des sciences anglais anglais
dans son discours coin d'un discours qui
étaient reliés par la bbc les coupes
belle époque où mais l'époque où les
leçons inaugurales
et puis diffusée dans les radios grande
audience il disait que toute personne
qui parle de extraire l'énergie de
l'atome
rappelons donc à cette époque en avait
la relativité restreinte et on savait
que la quantité d'énergie on à gazinet
part de la masse était proportionné le
carré de la vitesse de la lumière
le gala mc carey la fin deux équations
d'einstein nous dit que pour une masse
donnée m on assez carré fois m en
énergie ce qui est très très très très
très très très très très très très
grands comme quantité d'énergie et donc
certains physiciens comment se dire oui
mais en fait si on arrive à extraire
l'énergie juste de la matière sans son
extra d'énergie du mouvement de la
matière au lieu d'extraire l'énergie
d'un barrage ou ou d'une turbine ou d'un
moteur à charbon extrait juste de la
tôle safra ils ont fait des calculs ils
ont vu que c est normal en fait
auteur forte dans son discours à la
royal society disait anyone suggesting
that will extract et donc toute personne
suggérant qu'on extrait l'énergie de
l'atome et sport qu'il monte charest en
train de parler d'eux
rêve debout record est important qu'ils
racontent n'importe quoi et l'éosine
hard qui à écouter ce discours le
lendemain c'était cette élite
littéralement le lendemain un jour après
il ay les partis déposer son idée de
réaction en chaîne
donc la base de toute la physique
atomique toute l'énergie nucléaire
d'aujourd'hui les réactions en chaîne
donc il y là il s'est rendu compte que
en fait si juste réfléchir sur et si on
arrive à provoquer une réaction en
chaîne à entretenir
parlez-nous tron qui reviennent et on en
arriverait à extraire l'énergie de
l'atome est depuis en un des réacteurs
nucléaires des bons et malheureusement
aussi des bombes muller donc faut se
méfier des déclarations de certitudes
y compris quand texan émises par la
sommité du domaine on parle de retour
forcé la sommité de la physique atomique
du jour où il parlait c'était contredire
le long de l'entrée
donc oui c'est faux faux faux c'est un
sujet où il faut pas exclure un futur
beaucoup plus problématique que ce qu'on
a vu aujourd'hui que les manipulations
électorales de 2016 peuvent nous
paraître assez bisounours par rapport à
ce qu on pourrait avoir plus beaucoup
bien pire oui et donc en fait s'il faut
faire un peu plus d'écouté discours de
l'anticipation des effets secondaires
non pas juste dire oui le fait que
rattraper vaste voilà heureusement que
veut heureusement que des gens en créant
en ce sens dit que les catastrophes
nucléaires fallait à peu près voir parce
que sinon je sur l'omx aura été bien
pire tout autre kukushima tchernobyl ça
aurait été bien pire que ce qui a eu lui
aussi il n'y avait pas une science de la
sécurité des réacteurs nucléaires a
coûté de la science des réacteurs
nucléaires
tiens il ya
les rues et les os qui parle du safety
mindset de l'état d'esprit pro sécurité
mais c'est vrai que dans le monde de
l'intelligence artificielle des
chercheurs en intelligence artificielle
ça c'est des gens qui travaillent
énormément sur la performance comme sur
faire des algorithmes joue toujours plus
capable tu vois plus puissants font des
trucs toujours plus en plus
impressionnant il n'est donc
valorisation de sa et une certaine du
coup les gens parlent de ça et il quand
les gens parlent que de ça on est humain
on m a dit d'arrêter une valorisation
fait ça surtout on ne pense pas qu'il
est le problème avec ça c'est le truc
bien à faire et c'est un énorme danger
parce que du coup on va bloquer les gens
qui vont dire autre chose à voir
discours très différents alors qu' il ya
des vrais problèmes de sécurité qui par
un petit bémol à ce que tu viens de dire
en fait les deux dernières années dans
les conférences seniors en gros il ya
c'est le chantier de la sécu la
robustesse la sécurité vraiment
grossiste en a pour une triste raison
c'est parce que on a vu des examens ont
abrité la balle à cambridge analytique
allemagne c'est un mal pour un bien
c'est un mal c'est toujours à mal mais
c'est triste à dire mais heureusement
qu'il ya eu que cambridge à l'egypte
heureusement qu'on a eu qu un truc qui a
manipulé
l'élection de la plus grande puissance
mondiale mais ça va il peut être pire
mais grâce à dieu mais grâce à ça mais
personne ne se réjouit d'une
manipulation de masse aujourd'hui est de
plus en plus de recherches sur la
robustesse des systèmes d'orientation
etc
mais il aura fallu il aura fallu
cambridge à leyti kâ il aura fallu les
nombreux cas médiatisés de d'algorithmes
raciste biaisé envers les donc
discriminant envers les femmes etc de
manière spectaculaire parce que c'est
fait à grand échelle ou s'est fait sur
des technologies kankankan glory qu'on
présentait comme les technologies du
futur
il aura fallu ça pour que de plus en
plus de recherches mais c'est toujours
très insuffisant de séjour largement
suffisant
et puis ça c'est mon désir 20 avant que
ouija et hikaru 2016 vous parlez de tout
ça le match passe et tu vas enfin des
gens passer pour des milles nautiques
fin enfin moi je préférerais que les
thématiques sont arrivés avant de parler
avec un rémy des singularités et en 2016
et comme il dit à braver on va faire une
vidéo va se moquer d'eux abrège pas
besoin d'invoquer la singularité sort
que c'est très important pour ce bouquin
ça que il est pas buzz il n'est nul
besoin d'invoquer la singularité où les
hypothèses qui paraissent fantaisistes
il est même pas alors on va parler là
sur les dernières dix minutes de la
limite humaine de lire qui dépasserait
qui dépasserait potentiellement l'humain
il n'est même nul besoin d'invoquer tout
ça le livre ne parle d'ailleurs pas du
tout de l'île assurera humaines ou de la
singularité
le livre parle surtout de
l'automatisation du traitement de
l'information à très grande échelle et
les problèmes qu'ils posent c'est
important a entraîné il ya un chapitre
le juge fondamental le propos propos
majoritaire du livre à l'exception du
chapitre '66 sur la limite
d'intelligence on vous pouvez n'est pas
lire on sent les chapitres qui en parle
qui explique pourquoi il faudrait quand
même y jeter un coup d'oeil de
pansements les 16 sur 17 autres
chapitres n'évoque pas du tout sans
valable sans valable pour des
algorithmes déjà déployés trèbes est pas
très intelligent on est d'accord avec
les gens qui disent que l'ia
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas très intelligent
voilà c'est ça ça parait contre intuitif
ce que les gens disent oui tu as entendu
un tel il dit client n'est pas très
intelligente
alors que toi tu me dis que c'est très
dangereux oui c'est elle et elle est
très intelligente mais elle traite une
quantité de données
phénoménal qui font que les conséquences
de ces actions ont une grande ampleur
donc on est d'accord
elle n'est pas très intelligente et une
emil boc nul besoin qu'elles qu'elles ne
deviennent intelligents tanka que les
humains pour que soient promenade
lien n'est peut-être pas très
intelligente mais très puissante c'est
d'ailleurs le mot intelligent par la
crise et non pas dans les livres il n'y
a pas besoin de christian carme en
arguant qu'elles soient conscientes
c'est encore moins complètement
orthogonale et suffit qu'elle est une
ampleur à très grande échelle comme
c'est le cas déjà aujourd'hui je veux
revenir sur votre truc là c'est à dire
monaco était 3 heures parce que ce que
tu as dis qui je pense est vraiment
important pour motiver les gens à lire
le livre c'est que 1 écrivant ce livre
est à plusieurs in or et mende au moment
même où je suis a atteint je vous
comprends mieux moi même parce que c'est
réfléchi comme tu diras qu'est-ce que
réfléchir et on réfléchit aussi à quai
ce qui est bien et comment est-ce que
notre cerveau fait pour déterminer ce
qui est bien que ce qu'on considère bien
et ça c'est une réflexion absolument
fantastique en scène d un des trucs les
plus plus fantastique que en écrivant ce
livre
dias avec a tellement d'autres domaines
la psychologie bien sûr si le film aura
bien sûr mais enfin c'est tellement liée
à des phénomènes sociologiques avec
phénomène d'économie france est vraiment
ultra clos disciplinaire et c'est juste
par coire ce livre j'ai dit aux gens de
lire par attention bien sûr mais c'est
vraiment le sentiment que j'ai eu en
écrivant ce livre j'ai juste découvert
énormément de choses sur moi même donc
je pense juste cherché à accomplir ce
chantier sera des conséquences positives
sur les indices présentés en service sur
les algorithmes et ça aussi c'est
également extrêmement épanouissant à
titre individuel
c'est un peu au cours de ces dernières
années en écrivant à redire à la formule
du savoir miro précédent affiché en
direct avec bâtons mieux tout ça
juste me semble beaucoup plus épanoui je
me comprend beaucoup mieux
c'est beaucoup plus calmes beaucoup plus
j'adore ces réflexions précédant des
élections
fascinante et ça me permet aussi
d'insister sur le bo fabuleux on sait ce
titre vraiment je pense que c'est un
fabuleux chantier c je suis alors
qu'armand est un peu de stratégie
communication mais c'est vraiment ce que
je crois que c'est vraiment le les
questions de recherche que je trouve le
plus fascinant aujourd'hui pendant
longtemps sa visité dans les maths et
tout ça
tess de rim a dû tout ça donne quand
j'étais en puzzle m'intéresser à des
trucs semi concret va dire mais ce qui
m'intéressait c'était les maths
au fait il ya débat de fascinantes aussi
sur le tableau chantier il ya vraiment
des questions fantastique
il ya un projet de recherche en train de
regarder le tableau à jour car je ne
sais pas s'ils ont des questions
abordées dans le vivre et c'est vraiment
un truc facile en revanche je pense que
ça serait d'accord dire que c'est des
trucs qui vit juste change ma
compréhension du monde et ça s'est passé
un point de psychologique c'était un
point de vue un algorithme hic mais
c'est aussi d'un point de vue social un
point de vue économique organisation de
société pour des questions vraiment
centrale et c'est vraiment le fait que
j'aimerais que les gens retiennent un
peu de ça c'est que c'est pas s'ils en
place il ya un côté fascinant et moi je
pense que c'est vraiment le plus
fabuleux des chantiers que à mener dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
elle espère qu'une c'est cool mais bon
ça changerait pas la lune alors que
accomplir seul fabio chantier qui est
peut-être que ces intellectuels du coup
moins spectaculaires tout ça
mais ça va vraiment vous retourner le
cerveau ne recontre très vivement
lecture du livre justement trop se
disait un peu la même chose à présent il
me disait que in the process bats un
truc comme ça j'ai en gros
en fait quand on réfléchit à comment
comment donner un objectif bénéfique
un outil de traitement automatisé
d'informations en finit par faire de
l'introspection sur nous-mêmes enfin
comment nous mêmes on se donne des
objectifs de traitement de l'information
mais je vais encore if du couple passe
mon temps à corriger des copies du toit
mais moi je pense corriger des copies et
puis des fois je me dis oui mais non là
c'est pas équitable envers les étudiants
parce que je suis va faire une
introduction en fait c'est quoi
l'objectif de l'examen c'est d'évoluer
l'étudiant sur son assignation du court
mais et si cette parade on finit vite
par se rendre compte qu'en fait notre
forme et manière de formuler la question
est peut être la cause de l'erreur de
l'étudiant par exemple cc c'est une
bêtise basique des gens qui ont
peut-être une expérience pédagogique
plus plus longue que la mienne en
probablement pu voir ça de d'une autre
manière mais personnellement en fait
c'est en posant la question
on veut donner envie communiqué formulé
en fonction d'objectifs on veut l'écrire
et en fait qu'est-ce qui peut tourner
mal en fait des cours dès qu'on se met à
écrire des consignes et à écrire on va
toujours trahir temps on dit souvent
traduire c'est trahir en fait parler
c'est trahir que tu vois c'est le une
des choses que juqu'en savoir après la
crise lire c'est pas juste traduire qui
trahir traduire du français à l'anglais
ou du français vers l'arabe où je sais
pas en fait parler c'est trahir d'écran
formule en langage en caractère fini dès
qu'on écrit
entre aïn ce qu'en pensait vraiment
notre intention est l'enjeu aujourd'hui
ce que l'on veut donner à des machines
des intentions objectif à la un objectif
qui doit traduire nos intentions
le problème c'est que entre nous et la
machine goulot d'étranglement
c'est la parole l'écriture ont juste à
quand ça va mal on va gagner ça va aller
moi ça va beaucoup car moi j'ai entendu
ça va des fois je me dis si je réponds
aux gens juste trahir ce que je ressens
on n'arrive pas à dire ce qu'on recevra
est-ce que ça va oui je suis une femme
sketches je sais pas ce que j'ai ou
c'est difficile de traduire ont des mots
de la langue française
des gens d'enseignement que natal on
sait juste à la difficulté de dire ce
que vous ressentez quand on vous le
demande
là c'est pire vous voulez écrire en
python au langage informatique une
intention et quelle que soit la forme
avec laquelle vous allez écrire vous
allez vous rendre compte que vous avez
traduit cette aventure il est très
difficile de traduire une intention et
ou de pire en fait on pensait être sept
on pense à une intention et quand on
réfléchit à ce que ça va provoquer oms
en compte non c'est parce que je voulais
d'abord maximise maximise le nombre de
cloud par maximiser la production dit
mais comment je vais maximiser la
production maxis le nombre de cloud je
commence à faire plein de cloud léger
annoncé parce que je voulais parce que
les clubs les jeux ne se vante pas
maximise les couples qui se vantent je
trouve qu'il ya un clou bizarre qui
n'est pas du tout utile mais qui se font
beaucoup je commence à en fait dès que
dès que j'écris des intentions il ya un
problème à personne personnellement
c'est lui
si je devais dire un truc de conclusion
qu'est ce que qu'est ce que je vois
vraiment différent c'est le goulot
d'étranglement de la parole et
d'expression humaine
la difficulté des produits de lessive et
parce qu'il faut formuler donc voilà je
fait je me rendais pas compte à quel
point la parole qui quand même quelque
chose qui nous différencie
fondamentalement de beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'animaux c'est quand même un
outil de communication qui est qui est
pas encore à la hauteur de ce temps qui
du coup très difficile à manipuler
ouais c'est comme ça il faut penser à un
entonnoir fait votre bouche c'est un
entonnoir
vous avez vos pensées mais quand vous
voulez les communiquer à votre proche
vous les fait passer par un entonnoir
qui s'appelle la langue et il ya un truc
qui sort de cet entonnoir après qui va
rendre fâché votre ami ou notre cousin
ou votre frère après oui non c'est parce
que je voulais dire voilà je vous
apporte rien de nouveau ici mais en fait
c'est face à ce type de problème en fait
aujourd'hui pour l'intelligence tir on
est face à ce type de problème mais on
veut dire on veut donner une fonction
objectif alignant un automatisme qui
traitent l'information
mais très vite on va se rendre compte
c'est parce que je voulais rapproche les
gens sur facebook de leur voisinage de
leur quartier
du coup on va citant voisins si c'est la
saison du vaccin et que ton voisin te
dit de pas de vacciner et que la situe
pas sauf d'être vaccinés à j'ai favorisé
le voisin du coup t'as pas vu le poste
de l'institut pasteur et du coup t'as
pas vaccinés pas un gamin c'est parce
que je voulais je voulais te rapprocher
de temps voisin sentent induire en
erreur en termes d'information médicale
a fallu y penser
cette difficulté d'anticiper dans les
effets secondaires de ce qu'on dit que
oui et du coup comment être robustement
bénéfices dans la manière dont ces
petits appareils ce qui s'est vraiment
pas facile moi j'ai soulevé un autre
truc qui me fait pas mal réfléchi à ça
on fait beaucoup réfléchir mais un autre
truc c'est les décompositions la rnt est
charlie bob
et alice je me demande maintenant
régulièrement dans mon cerveau si
j'arrive à faire cette exposition est ce
que j'arrive à faire en sorte qu'elle
collecte de données soit vraiment aussi
certifié valide que ce que ça faudrait
pas ce que je fais vraiment de
l'inférence comme il faut par rapport à
ces données je les mélange plein temps
avec mes préférences ensuite parce que
je calcule vraiment bien ce que je
voudrais vouloir parce que ce que je
veux de façon addictives
ensuite est-ce que j'ai bien bob qui
fait qu'ils qui garde parce que tout ce
circuit face au oui voudraient vouloir
[ __ ] au cul c'est mon dernier mot
cette fois je m'arrête
c'est là la révolution l'abolition
extrapolé une de mes autres bonnes
rencontres dans cette réflexion
trois années de discussions puis ces
derniers dix 10 mois de tant de boucan
c'est cette notion de volition cohérente
extrapoler
donc en fait très brillant et une très
bonne vidéo de l'est qui coûte ce propos
donc une différence
en fait on se rend compte qu'il ya une
différence entre penser à l'exemple de
la parole donc vous dites à votre frère
quelque chose et vous rendez compte que
c'est parce que vous voulez dire et
c'est en fait c'est pareil mais pour
vous ou l'un de vos préférences propre
tête
par exemple que vous aimez vous aimez
vous aimez les parts
mais vous savez que ça vous créer des
problèmes vous êtes diabétique et vous
aimerez ne pas aimer l'état en fait vous
aimerez ne pas aimer letarte les parts
mais une partie de vous qui aiment les
tartes dans le temps immédiatement et
qui risque de prendre le dessus et de
prendre la tarte
en fait la notion de volition cohérente
extrapolé elles généralisent ce dilemme
qu'on a tout le temps entre ce qu'on
voudrait maintenant est ce qu'on aurait
voulu si on était plus informés si on
s'était posé à réfléchir qu'une entente
et c'est en fait c'est encore ses traits
algorithmique parce que il ya la notion
de combien on vient on a réfléchi encore
mais on a calculé la notion de caen
simples comme la complicité en
échantillonnage combien on a vu
l'exemple
donc si c'est en fait c'est donc si je
ne réfléchis pas trop si je ne m'informe
pas trop si je n'y pense pas vraiment je
vais sauter sur la tarte
mais si je me pose un peu si je médite
un peu plus longtemps
je calcule en fait je réfléchis plus je
regarde plus d'exemples dans la
littérature de personnes ont eu des
problèmes de sucre etc
je vais pas prendre à la partie et en
fait des vieillards qui voudraient avoir
un objectif non pas écrit par les
humains mais appris en observant les
humains et aujourd'hui en fait
aujourd'hui un responsable très haut
placé de facebook a déclaré dans une
discussion publique que facebook à des
fonctions objectif en fait est en train
ils sont en train de je pense que c'est
une bonne chose
ils sont en train d'abandonner les
fonctions objectif écrite à la main ou
maximiser l'engagement d'utilisateurs
est en train d'essayer d'avoir des
fonctions objectif appris en observant
les utilisateurs c'est très séduisant
c'est ce que nos lieux de donner une
fonction d'objectifs écrite à la main et
je veux apprendre en observant et le
problème se pose encore en termes de
sécurité
le livre aborde c'est un peu c'est que
si on observe les préférences humaine
probablement on va surtout observer
cette version qui n'a pas beaucoup
réfléchi qui n'a pas beaucoup regarder
les données et qui a mangé la tarte est
alors qu'en fait c'est plus safe c'est
plus sécurisé de ne pas apprendre de
cette version 2 mois donc si on observe
mois en fait j'aimerais ne pas
j'aimerais que l'algorithme n'observe
pas le mois qui craquent qui montrent la
tarte
j'aimerais qu'ils apprennent du mois qui
se pose qui médite qui regardent des
exemples qui s'informent sur le sucre
est bête et qui ne mange pas la tarte
donc j'aimerais qu'il ya conclu que
maximiser les tares que manger c'est pas
ma fonction objectif c'est un peu la
distinction entre système limbique
système et cortex n'est les gens qui
utilisent un peu le cerveau irak pas de
sortir cet exemple que le drame de
l'humain c'est que c'est un cortex qui
doit satisfaire un système limbique donc
là la notion de cohérente de volition
avec l'écho à colin d'extrapoler
paraissait notion très philosophique que
j'ai personnellement j'aurais pas pu
découvrir si je m'intéressais pas au
problème de la ligne on n'est évidemment
c'est un produit qui fonctionne bien qui
vient l'infection autour des yeux dont
deco ski et d'autres 40
clairement été très agité bob située
beaucoup bossé suite il doit prendre
soin de tout ce cirque eu la récompense
c'est une bonne question de me pose
souvent parce que je réfléchisse comme
il faut réfléchir et quels sont les
incitatifs que je dois me donner
internes ou externes pour vous motiver à
mieux réfléchir et à mieux vouloir ce
que je voudrais vouloir tant de
questions absolument fascinante et
j'espère que ça vous a intéressé
le concurrent non je te laisse conclure
j'espère que vous avez fait que ça vous
a vraiment intrigué que si vous avez
trouvé qu'on était un peu confus combat
c'est un peu du coq à l'âne et tout est
beaucoup mieux réalisés dans votre livre
que si vous leur en savoir plus ou
atours de fête le chantier en
intelligence artificielle russe au moins
bénéfique
il crie pas remédié mois aux éditions e
dp science merci et à bientôt
probablement car ce